so the first poll is out following joe
biden's anti-maga speech and the
majority of americans didn't like it
they felt that it was dangerous they
felt that it was escalating conflict in
this country and that it was incitement
to conflict so that's around 60 percent
now here's the best part democrats
overwhelmingly liked it republicans and
independents do not like it and here's
the best part among independent voters
joe biden's approval rating is in the
gutter 2-1 disapproval for joe biden he
keeps pandering to the the hardest far
left of the democratic party it's making
everybody in this country uh it's
putting everybody on edge it's
escalating the threats of violence and
conflict just i agree with people who
are who are polled
and in the end he's losing the middle
ground because they're chasing after
twitter
now we have the story from daily mail
that wealthy liberals are buying golden
visas to other countries preparing to
flee in the event there's a civil war
that trump is leading it or that fascism
comes back to america so i just want to
shout out to all of those conservatives
who are like huh all these liberals talk
about leaving the country why aren't
they leaving well the rich ones at the
very least they have the means to do it
and it looks like they're preparing to
do it so we'll talk about that
california is apparently facing rolling
blackouts so uh
yeah that's well that's their own fault
and then you have probably the best
story
the funniest story i've read in a long
time jennifer lawrence says that she has
recurring nightmares about tucker
carlson
yo
y'all need to calm down a little bit
before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member if you want
to support our work
as a member you'll get access to the
uncensored after show that goes up about
11 p.m so sign up at timcast.com and
you'll also get to watch cast castle
tales of the inverted world now i know a
lot of people wanted wanted to see cast
castle we were delayed because of labor
day everybody had the day off so we just
tried to double time it and i think it's
like 22 or 23 minutes long so it's a bit
longer and it's uh it's great so it
should be up at some point but you know
check it out when you can don't forget
to smash that like button and subscribe
to this channel share the show right now
take that url post it everywhere you can
if you really want to help us out
joining us today to talk about this and
so much more is corey mills
how are you who are you good sir uh so
i'm the republican nominee out of uh
florida seven uh combat veteran business
owner father patriot and uh apparently
i'm a deplorable and extremist oh wow
all those things but you won the primary
so you're you're basically set to uh
it's like an aoc kind of thing where she
won the primary and everyone said she's
gonna win the general because it's like
it leans republican is that what's
happening yeah so it's pretty much a
safe r seat at this point especially
after the redistricting so it was
originally kind of a pvi even district
but it was leaning d5 and now it's an
you know r7 leaning r15
so you know this really was about the
primary race we had a very contested
primary we had eight it was an eight-way
race i mean we had everything from
a former state rep to a former vice
mayor to a navy seal to a business owner
so um you know it was a very contested
and very heated race but uh the primary
pretty much was the entire race right on
cool man well thanks for joining us
thanks for having me we got daniel
turner always great to be back here love
it hi everyone daniel turner power the
future america's
greatest fossil fuel advocate energy
expert extraordinaire and virginia's
greatest sheep farmer bristol farm
virginia on instagram yes
yes you know what we'll get to this
later on but i just bought a whole bunch
more used yesterday drove them back to
the farm use a female sheep that you
inseminate right and as i was driving
them home i was thinking how new blood
is so important to a farm because you
can't have dads you know have sex with
their daughters new blood is important
and new blood is important in dc also
because when you get the same stale
blood and you pass your seed on to your
son or daughter
you have a lot of bad dc so new blood in
dc is great as well so thanks for being
our you
we're going to talk a bit about farming
too because one of the stories that we
have is this uh writer for the guardian
saying if there really is going to be a
civil war i'm screwed
no guns no bunker no food i'll last a
week and it's like thank you for it for
acknowledging that's the truth but now
you can change these circumstances yeah
we also got ian children hi everyone
good to be here ian crossland what's up
dudes hey let's get down to brass tacks
shall we i am very excited for this
evening i always have a great time with
daniel and corey as well both repeat
customers i'm excited to get into it
let's go all right here's the story from
the dailymail.com loaded liberals are
paying millions for golden visas to
other countries because they're scared
of a trump-led civil war in 2024. i said
civil war that means wealthy wokes
planned their escape but why didn't they
go in 2016. now i will say right off the
bat i'm a bit skeptical but also kind of
not like part of me wants to think it's
it's an exaggeration but part of me kind
of believes it we already saw the story
about these billionaires who are trying
to build bunkers and and resorts in new
zealand and stuff and that story's been
like going on for a long time you had
the ceo from reddit who's also one of
these woke wealthy liberals talking
about survival prepping and getting food
because they saw something coming
daily mail says the wealthy wokes are
spending huge sums to bag visas that
allow them to escape to countries like
austria turkey jordan and the caribbean
according to attorneys running the
process consultants say they've seen a
massive spike in interest for
citizenship for second countries all
over the uh countries over the last few
years many americans told them they are
petrified by the thought of another
trump administration
while others cited the roe v wade ruling
in the 2008 crash you know what i love
about that
if you want to leave the united states
because you're worried about abortions
yeah go to jordan or turkey we'll see
how that works out if you want to leave
america because you're worried about
authoritarianism is is turkey right the
great the the best runner up is canada
yeah this is the craziest thing i see
with this and people like i'm gonna move
to canada it's like okay well like they
they they were arresting people trying
to leave their homes they called truck
drivers fascists and extremists i mean
we got similar issues going on here in
the u.s but i don't think going to
jordan no you know
yeah i was just to say i think that it's
a it's greatly exaggerated i think that
we have to understand that historically
a lot of billionaires and even
multi-millionaires look for areas to
park money that has the best taxation
clauses i mean that's why you have
countries in
uh the caribbean like bermuda things
like this as a two percent uh tax treaty
with america so they park their you know
cash off there you have the uae in dubai
who has a dmz which is a tax free hub
and
things like this i don't think it has
anything to do i think they're trying to
utilize this as an excuse i think the
real reason they're doing is that
they're looking at the increased
inflation taxation what's going on in
america and the fact that the dollar is
not going as far they probably saw 87
000 new irs agents
exactly maybe i should be a citizen it's
trump's fault i also love like rich
liberals that you know took a private
helicopter from amman to petra and
they're like jordan is paradise
i live in georgia i was like well yeah
that's great it's like you know you got
your tour of the hagia sophia and you're
like i could live in istanbul sure you
could but i i will just caution and
remind everyone that during president
trump's
time in office you actually had more
billionaires and multi-millionaires
moving their cash back onshore to
america and you had businesses returning
to america so i think that
this great exaggeration that they're
fleeing because they're worried about
another trump administration which i'm
certainly hoping for one i think it's
completely far-fetched and they're
running away from the realities because
that doesn't add up to what actually
happened from 16 to 20. peter navarro
was on the show and he was saying well
at least give me that we had the best
economy of our lives or whatever and i i
said no i think that the balloon was
about to burst because of our 24
trillion deficit or uh debt and he was
like oh because he but at the same time
what he was did do well is they were
bringing business back which and it
seemed like it's been a while since
there was a resurgence of american
industry
and they were doing their part right i
mean right now we've got a gdp to
national debt ratio of about 131 percent
so you're talking about an insolvency as
a business owner that means you don't
qualify for a loan that doesn't i mean
that means that you're spending 31 over
what your incoming revenue is so you
know at this stage the only thing that
props up america is the fact that we
have the us dollars being global
currency which is exactly what china
russia and iran is trying to eliminate
is the u.s dollar from being the global
currency that's the whole point of their
kind of geopolitical alignment they've
been doing that for a long time but now
they're almost close when you talk about
the fact that one they're already
expanding the eurasian border they take
over africa oceania create the maritime
silk route cut off supply chain to the
western hemisphere because we're getting
drug into these endless wars like we're
seeing in ukraine when the reality is is
that this is about economic resource
warfare this isn't about kinetics any
longer you know what's weird about this
article if i could just say if i'm the
the democrat adviser to the biden
campaign world if your wealthy liberals
are already banking on a trump win you
have to be nervous about your campaign
strategy right they're already if
they're already planning to leave then
they don't think he's going to win
perhaps i think a lot of it's probably
that they're saying okay it looks like
trump is going to win so i'm going to
hedge my bets but but i'll be honest too
in in the the source article which comes
from the daily beast they mention
for years david lesperance an
immigration attorney who helps wealthy
americans obtain second citizenships saw
a similar type of client millionaire
maga heads silicon valley libertarians
new money crypto investors basically
rich guys who wanted out of the us tax
system
but in recent months he's seen an
increase in a surprising clientele
moneyed liberals who are terrified of
the political future of the country and
want an escape plan
i think after everything we've seen i
mean look they're talking about rolling
blackouts in california perhaps they
should have managed their energy
production better but
these people they here's what i think
as an aside
they campaign on climate change and then
have no choice but to follow through
with with cutting off their own
electrical grid
to appease their own voters and they're
they're spinning themselves into
oblivion now california is in serious
trouble they couldn't get
they they couldn't build
enough generation to to maintain their
own state despite the fact they've been
screaming about it endlessly
now you have people who are suffering
their own problems leaving places like
california and going to arizona or texas
and bringing their problems or their
voting patterns with them but then you
have the wealthy who are looking at all
the problems they created all of the
cheering on of the the the you know
going after trump defense of of of
hunter and joe biden and their illicit
business dealings
there's going to be accountability we
saw this in in early 2020 or mid-2020
when the boston globe reported on war
games that were being held by democrats
and you know neocon establishment
republicans
and on the democrat side in the war game
they suggested the west coast secede
from the union if trump were to win
that's where they were in 2020 at least
according to the boston globe
when i hear that they're fleeing now
because they're scared about trump i say
yes and for the moneyed liberals i don't
think it's because they're they have
trump derangement syndrome i think it's
because these are the people who know
that they've been doing naughty things
and they're going to get caught when
when donald trump or republicans
it's not just any republican it's got to
be republicans who actually take action
actually file subpoenas no i think larry
hogan will go after these guys too i
can't even finish the comment without
laughing sorry i i'll tell you though i
i do think that there's a part of that
but i also think that you're starting to
see
a lot more currency hedging as well
where people are actually going and
parking their money offshore they're
exchanging their currency and trading on
the markets and they're you know making
a killing on it basically betting and
shorting the dollar and so
um you know i think a lot of these
people they just have the the amount of
money that's necessary to go ahead and
try and continue to create more wealth
and they're doing on the backs of
hard-working americans do you think that
they're actually
fleeing's an interesting phrasing but do
you think they're just increasing their
portfolio exactly
and then and finding a way to save money
especially with the the you know it's
funny because that's why i said bermuda
by the way because they literally have a
two percent tax treaty and there's
things that people will go and buy like
insurance captives and then they will do
something in one of their businesses
they will file an insurance claim
against it pay themselves out insurance
claims aren't taxed and then they're
basically just circumventing the system
so you know this is where the idea of
needing 87 000 deep state police added
into our system with the 600 000 in
small caliber ammunition isn't the fix
it's actually fixing the loopholes and
making sure that we hold those
accountable who are actually trying to
do these things i think the the the
money liberal types and look the
democratic party's become the party of
the wealthy vox.com said this not fox
vox vox
said in 2016 the democrats had become
the party of the wealthy they've they've
been coming they've become whiter and
wealthier over the past several
elections which is which is funny and
the republican party's becoming more
diverse and more working class
so of course
these are people who are like
well with joe biden making these moves
to raise taxes and stuff i got to do
what i got to do
you know and what i see with joe biden's
move in the democrats move with the irs
for instance they're not going to go
after the rich people no because the
rich people fight back if you if if the
irs sends a bill to a millionaire and
says you owe us x he'll be like
you know he'll get in the call to his
law firm and say hey handle this for me
and the beck you got it and then the irs
got to deal with it and they're like
we're going to lose money in man hours
send the bill for 500 bucks to that
working class joe who can't afford to
fight back that's right do that to 10
000 working class joes and we're gonna
make a pretty penny yeah and you will
you'll just you'll just pay the fine
because you can't afford the attorneys
and we were just saying before we went
live you know this is what this was the
strategy of mayor bowser in in
washington dc as the city was struggling
for revenue she hired
thousands more more meter maids we used
to call them and you know you show up to
your car you're totally within your
limits you've
obeyed all the signs all the parking
rules you paid but you have a 35 ticket
50 ticket and what are you gonna do
you're gonna take a day off of work to
go stand before a judge for fifty
dollars no you curse you scream you pay
the fifty dollars and they and she knows
that's what you're gonna do she doesn't
care about truth or justice and that's
what these irs agents are gonna do maybe
not you know 50 but honestly if i got a
500 irs fine
i can't that's my lawyer's fees would be
more than that exactly you're going to
curse you're going to scream and you'll
be like damn it and here's the 500 i
remember one time i got two tickets in
the mail that were
a final notice 150 i think was due two
of them 300 bucks and this was back when
i was making like 10 bucks an hour
working at the airport in chicago and i
was like what did i get tickets for
looked him up and it said i had
illegally parked in chicago months ago
never got a ticket on my car no never
parked illegally and when i called them
and said this must be a mistake they
said well you didn't respond to the
first two so now it's too late you have
to pay it's a final determination and i
said i never got a ticket doesn't matter
prove to me you didn't get it yup
exactly that's very common prove that
you didn't get it i think that's that's
fascinating uh that's metaphysically
well but this is the way it works right
it's it's guilty until proven innocent
not innocent until proven guilty the way
it was originally set yeah and it shows
you you just mentioned the california
thing
it shows you what i think a lot of
government and government bureaucrats
what they really think of their
constituents right like
yeah exactly you know like we don't care
about what this is bad for you if this
isn't inconvenient if this is illegal
unconstitutional we don't care that tim
didn't do this we just need his damn
money but i'll tell you this is why you
know when i talk to my my you know more
moderate liberal types friends and they
tell me they're in favor of defunding
the police this is exactly why yeah so i
was talking to a friend of mine who
lives in like a well-off suburban area
and i was like why would you want to
defund the police you live in the
suburbs that's where the cops are good
and she said it's because we all keep
getting pulled over and we don't do
anything wrong and they tell us to go to
court over it and we can't and we're all
like everyone's been talking about we're
pissed and then i was like well i get it
i completely get it if if you're seeing
something in your community like quota
systems or something then you're going
to be like don't know don't care but i
tell you this the funny repercussion of
that is going to be you may be upset
they're milking money out of you but you
get rid of the police and then see what
happens yeah well that's what we're
seeing right now which is increased
criminality i mean that's exactly what's
going on lawlessness and then you have
the democrats solved on crime policies
you have these catch and release
policies these nobel policies and you're
seeing an increase and now people are
terrorized to go out in areas that are
democrat controlled like seattle and new
york etc let's let's talk about that we
have this uh story from the guardian
which um i respect i respect this story
no doomsday bunker not a single gun if
the us really is heading for civil war
i'm stuffed says ara madawi the super
rich are preparing to ride at the
apocalypse by their underground swimming
pools ordinary americans have bought
another 20 million firearms and me i
have a broom and a butter knife
i i have tremendous respect for her
recognizing everyone else is going out
buying guns and she won't the best part
is when she says she'll last a week she
says how long do you think you would
survive if everything went to hell civil
war erupted institutions crumbled and
there was absolutely nowhere safe in the
world left to run me i'd give myself one
week maybe two maybe two that's generous
ladies
i would like to think that i'm a tough
survivor type the last time i went
camping i forgot to bring a sleeping bag
and sobbed myself to sleep so on balance
i would have to admit that i'm not i did
have a brief period this year when in a
fit of madness i thought i'd take up
urban farming and become as
self-sufficient as possible with a scrap
of garden in philadelphia that seemed to
go well until i proudly sent my mom a
photo of the luscious berry bushes i had
cultivated and she informed me that they
were poisonous weeds and i should get
rid of them immediately so yeah i don't
give myself great odds on surviving the
apocalypse uh
i respect that i i actually respect that
yeah yeah but look i don't want this
lady to get hurt i don't want her i want
her to survive i want her to
understand and maybe this is the first
step in realizing that the world is not
some fancy beautiful skittle and rainbow
bubble where you can go around and do
whatever the hell you want that there
are real dangers and we're kept safe by
a military and policing habits of being
not maybe not attacked by a wild animal
i'm not encouraging that anyone gets
attacked by a wild animal when an animal
comes at you like i'm watching videos of
like a wild boar attacking someone you
realize this world wants you dead
everything about the universe is out
there nature is metal space will kill
you if you go out there too far you say
the universe wants you yes it wants to
explode you in its vacuum if you get
near it
we're up against a mountain of of terror
and but we've lost that realization
being in these cities all compacted it
was canada right the wild boar thing i
didn't know where it was from it was
somewhere where they're only allowed
where they're only allowed to have three
rounds or something italy italy
yeah and the boar comes at him it's like
a is it a guy it was a high voice i
thought it was a woman but i and you see
the boom miss boom miss point blank miss
and then you start beating with the gun
it's like well now people ask why do you
need 30 rounds because that board would
not have been a threat to the individual
and boris can destroy you i'm very
likely i grew up hog hunting so i know
the dangers of of wild boar especially
even bar hawks down in the state of
florida and i mean you can get boar hogs
down there that are 300 400 pounds you
know four and a half six inch tush and
you know they basically i saw where you
know people would blood out because
they'll essentially grab them right
between you know kind of the crotch and
sever the femoral artery and i mean you
know you're stuck in the woods sitting
there bleeding out behind the pines and
palmettos so
it's a real risk one of the funniest
things i remember was when i had a
friend who went i think it was in
arizona
and they told me that they were locked
down and i was like whoa what's going on
they're like javelina spotting and i was
like what they're like javelin i'm like
what is that and they sent me a picture
of this little pig and i was like i was
like that that's why everyone's forced
inside and it's like yeah those things
will destroy them like they're how big
are they like the little wild pigs out
there in the desert or something like
that
dude
at the at least those kids in college
understood
like those little wild pigs or whatever
they are is that they're called javelina
am i pronouncing it right i honestly
i've never heard of it i've never heard
of those little pigs yeah yeah yeah
i've got a lot of compassion for animals
and humans being part of that animal
kingdom but like when i had a raccoon
peccary i went near a raccoon and i was
like okay i'm gonna use my magic on this
thing and be kind with the raccoon it
was in a cage but it screamed like it
wanted to kill me and i realized i gotta
the viciousness in me came out i was
like uh that thing can die yeah i will
eradicate all raccoons if that's a
danger to my survival
peccary is that right
yeah peccaries i guess you know so look
how cute the little baby is i know right
that thing would probably bite you and
give you rabies or who knows what you
see that video of the lady getting
attacked by the fox yeah
yeah yes
so i just want to say you know we've
done a bunch of discussions over the
years
talking about
you know would liberals survive the
apocalypse and it's funny when i hear
people try and make the argument that
it's not the case that liberals wouldn't
survive and i'm like dude the people in
cities would be eating each other in
like a week she says she'd last a week
maybe too dude when there's no water
what do you think people are going to do
yeah
it's like
ocean water for sure some people will
they'll drink the river water and then
die faster yeah it'll be quick yeah wow
man water man they said water new gold
dysentery and all the other things not
understanding how to boil water not
understanding how to you know check
things i mean yeah look i don't care how
many survival shows you try to watch and
you know the last frontier or alone i
mean at the end of the day if you don't
have proper survival skills you don't
have them yeah boiling water will kill
microbes but it doesn't get rid of like
a lot of stuff and it's very hard
critical isn't boil water if there's no
natural gas or there's no
your stove doesn't work do these people
know how to make a fire fire and you
know maintain a fire yeah do they have
any idea how to start a fire without
well i'll just get a lighter go to the
cvs there is no cvs do you know how to
hide a fire from people that want your
flight this is where people you start
asking so have you ever built a friction
fire do you understand you know how to
build fires in different elevations and
in different climates and how to
maintain that and how to transfer
because you know you can't just build a
fire and think that you're going to live
in one place forever maybe you're having
a transporter fire how do you do that
how do you tender how do you i i would
love to s i would really love to see
some of these people who have grown up
in these downtown you know metropolitan
areas where they've just always had
something at the tip of their finger
live for a week or even two as she said
oh my gosh if their uber each driver is
five minutes late they get zero stars
and they said raging instagram like this
is absurd and they want you know like
you think what they build a fire imagine
the people i grew up in the south so for
us it was like my grandfather taught us
to live in the woods
the people who think words are violence
yeah they'll be out in the streets
in an apocalyptic scenario and there's
going to be some dude with the gun who's
hungry and he's going to he's
these people probably many of them won't
get to encounter words at all but how
will they respond to someone actually
grabbing them yeah just like fall to the
ground how many of them will yell for
the police if seeing in a way if seeing
ben shapiro in the concert hall made you
like literally shake with fear get ready
when it's a bear right and you don't
have you have no idea how to use a gun
like maybe you have a gun do you have
any idea how to load it how to fire the
apocalypse happens the cities are wiped
out and ben shapiro's already created a
small working city
and then the liberals are outside the
walls screaming how terrified they are
of him and they're telling stories
they're you know it's like and then the
people who aren't insane will just knock
on the door and be like good sir i'm
looking for a job in food it's like we
are in need of someone of your specialty
come on in and they're outside screaming
terrified of ben shapiro
but so that's what i was saying earlier
i was like look
i'm not i'm not going to pretend like i
think i would survive
um for one i'm out of the city in the
middle of nowhere and i've started
learning and um and and
you know setting myself up in a way that
i would last longer than two weeks we
have emergency food we have bug out
locations we've got solar stuff and i've
been reading a bit obviously we have the
chickens but i'm not going to pretend
that i'd be better off than the average
say trump supporter who just grew up in
the country
they know what food they can already eat
outside like the first we have the
pawpaw out here the the hillbilly banana
they call it
i didn't even know where it was
last year i'm like i see these little
paw paws and i'm like looks like there's
three of them then papa season hit and
there's
50 000 of them everywhere like on the
ground literally i'm like it's just food
for days yeah and i had no idea and the
people out here were laughing because
they're like we know all about it what
you can where the berries are what kind
of berries you eat because they grew up
around it and i didn't so here's my
question for you guys how long do you
think you'd last let's say society
breaks down right now we can you know
this this liberal lady she's self-aware
but what do you think corey i mean i
think i could sustain fine on just my
own survival skills and the fact that i
have sustainable food i have you know
the ability to go ahead and have my own
water sources and not to mention that i
own a 2 000 acre facility that's well
armed so if i really needed to it comes
down to survival in the fittest i'll
take what i need
yeah that's that's kind of the point
it's like
it's not even necessarily about what you
know but it's about what you currently
have yeah you know i mean so i have
currency and currency is not money
that's what people have to understand
currency is things like ammunition
currency is things like food first for
trade currency is things like whiskey or
you know people have to understand that
in a society where
currency as far as you know it has
changed
now it becomes who is the most you know
the largest survival or the largest you
know kind of provider and store of goods
i mean this is why she talks about the
doomsday bunkers and the preppers you
know people make fun of preppers but i
can tell you right now that during the
unconstitutional lockdowns our family
never did without it's not just that
preppers are having fun yeah you know
what i've i watched these videos about
preppers and they always try to show you
the craziest guy who's like the waters
are coming so i got beans like that's
that's not real the real videos are
really great where it's a guy like oh
yeah we have here's where we store
emergency food we've got the animals
over there here's how it's basically
homesteading and we have like a you know
long story and they're having a good
time it's purpose they have purpose
they're doing what they love they enjoy
like we have the chickens the chickens
are fun what concerns me is when
people's purpose becomes defending
against an apocalypse because then it's
almost like they need the apocalypse in
order to fulfill their purpose i don't
want to take it that far let me let me
ask
if you were in a city let's say you're
on a business trip in new york you're in
manhattan right in the middle and then
all of a sudden just
everything just goes off
you'd you would still be completely fine
and that's that's kind of the point
right well yeah because my initial
instinct wouldn't be to sustain myself
in that city it would be to get back to
where i have all my supplies and and all
my sustainability for sure but i just
mean like
basic combat skills yeah i mean i'm i'm
gonna you know it's not like we sit in a
you know kind of empty solitude you know
building that has no food whatsoever i
mean you have enough to sustain you for
a number of days clearly my big thing
would be pack what i can get out get my
way a means of transportation and get to
where i have the most sustainability
which is my own facility the funny thing
is so many of these liberals would be
like they'd go outside and be like okay
everybody let's talk about what our plan
is and they just sit around it's like
you realize there's no water in this
place the water pressure is gone there's
no water it would be a lot no
conversation looking for who to serve
well i i think for a while you just have
an increase in criminality right so you
just have the stealing and looting of
basic goods or essentially the 2020
mostly
uh what is it
people of love yeah um i mean you'd
essentially just have that you'd have
rampant increase in criminality you'd
have a lot of theft you'd have murders
you'd have all these different things
going on but eventually when those
supplies run out
and there is no workforce and no one is
actually reproducing anything
then you'd have to go into true survival
skills as well
i like what you said about currency
because i did a thread the other day on
on social about the coming great
depression which i think is is
inevitable assuming the government
doesn't collapse right assuming i'm not
talking apocalypse i'm just talking
about like like the great depression of
our of our grandparents of old um and i
like what you said about currency
because i was telling people to start
keeping big supplies of of cash because
the black markets will pop up everywhere
and people like not necessarily tim but
people like tim who have extra chickens
will create a black market for eggs
because we're in a great depression cash
won't be the currency though that's the
whole thing well if the government has
gold billions and it'll have to be
things like fuel but my my my point was
it could be but my point was that though
that they're not going to take your
credit card they're not going to take
100 percent they're not going to take a
check they're not going to
take your gold yeah no they're going to
need something that they can easily
change that's assuming the government
hasn't collapsed which i don't think
it's going to i don't think we're headed
towards a towards an apocalypse i do
think we're headed towards a depression
though it's not just that it's that even
if the u.s collapsed other governments
would have to clap collapse for for
something like gold to lose its value
yeah right in in the event that the u.s
goes into chaos and their civil war
there's still going to be people who say
hey that gold is valuable in turkey that
gold is valuable in europe so i will
take it from you and bring it there
there's there's still going to be trade
going on
i just think that
in the event of a real civil war people
need to understand is that it's not
these regular liberal types this is what
i hear a lot from people they're like ah
i think it was bill um bill burr he's
the comedian right
he was saying something recently on tr i
think he's on trigonometry and it's it
shows you the danger of ignorance he's a
funny guy he's a good actor i respect
his his work but not his political
positions because
you know he said on joe rogan he's like
look joe i just put on the tv they tell
me to wear a mask i wear it or i don't
what two weeks later i'll turn it on
i'll do what they tell me that's the
kind of attitude where he says
he's on this on trigonometry regular
people don't care about this stuff you
go out nobody's talking about it and
that's that's that's ignorance of
history if i go out i went i went down
to like strasbourg and front royal the
other day yeah i'm in maga country of
course no one's fighting each other they
all live next to each other and have the
same politics you go into a city it's
it's woke country everybody's got the
flags of course no one's fighting each i
mean they're still fighting each other
to be honest but not always because
they're next to each other it's the
geographical differences where people
are spreading apart from each other
and what happens is in any major
conflict it is a small minority of the
people who are leading the fighting and
when you have the president uh donald
trump just called joe biden enemy of the
state joe biden called trump supporters
extremists and then tried walking it
back later and then doubled down and
said you know the funny thing is when he
says maga republicans are a threat and
so are their policies you know you know
he's talking about trump supporters
because they're the ones who are pushing
those policies and supporting those
people you have the highest levels of
government
there's a conflict happening it doesn't
matter what regular people are thinking
or doing it's that law enforcement the
the the the military apparatus are
currently being pointed at each other
sooner or later you get what met tybee
calls that arrest this man moment where
the cars rush to the police station two
guys jump out and point arrest that man
at each other and then the police
basically decide whose side are they on
that's when you figure out who's
fighting who but speaking of um you know
collapse and stuff let's jump to this
story from fox business
californians warned of possible rolling
blackouts as state battles historic heat
wave perhaps the collapse you know for
those are just joining with the segment
where this lady was saying if civil war
happened she wouldn't last a week maybe
she would maybe last two no guns no
bunkers no food perhaps it won't be a
civil war they have to worry about
perhaps it's just going to be rolling
blackouts i saw a video i think it was
out of italy where they're they're
they're going to school and working by
candlelight yeah yeah because the energy
costs are so high
so um well and you're starting to see
that even here in america where people
you know affordability of just your
basic utilities has gone up double if
not triple in some areas and i mean this
is impacting every single american it's
insane and you know i'm going to defer
to the energy expert here but i mean i
put a lot of this on the fact that we
have sustainable energy sources at our
disposal under our feet and they
continue to go to unreliable renewables
which we saw texas even try at one point
with their you know wind turbines and
they're now
you know regretting that decision i mean
we have to get back to energy
independence but we can do that through
the actual energy sources that are
reliable energy sources like coal and
gas and oil the things that are under
our feet nuclear nuclear as well
absolutely but look in california they
can't
they've they've culted themselves into a
corner they've told everybody we can't
do it because nuclear is bad and climate
change
i'll tell you this right now
i don't care what your position is on
climate change california objectively
screwed themselves energy-wise because
when you come out and say
carbon is bad and and burning all this
fossil fuels is making the climate worse
the response is okay nuclear is a good
option right totally green and it's got
an excellent energy return on energy
invested no no nuclear is bad as well
because nuclear is dirty three-mile
island
that's what everyone just says with
nuclear fukushima
and then the response is okay
go for wind i guess
good luck and now you get
rolling they're they're saying it's like
a stage two emergency in california
they can't build nuclear because they
campaigned on hating it they can't build
new uh you know fossil fuel plants they
campaigned on hating it and they don't
have the battery power for wind or solar
when marjory taylor green criticized i
think it was uh solar power
saying that when the sun goes down you
lose the power i like having the lights
on at night everyone laughed liberals
mocked her they're like oh you're so
dumb dude large-scale
solar systems there's not batteries for
this solar works really really well
during the day when you have the energy
and then has to be supplemented at night
with fossil fuels or nuclear salts kind
of i'll defer to you daniel you know
better than i do molten salt you
familiar with the molten salt reactors
no i mean molten salt blue hydrogen
there's lots of great things in theory
that i think
i would be fine seeing investors not the
government i would find
seeing them develop and if they work
it's great i welcome all technologies
but the problem is the electric grid is
for good or for ill it is run by the
state
right and and if the state is in charge
of giving you electricity then the state
has a responsibility to give you damn
electricity and the state is failing its
job they don't even know what
electricity is no they have no idea hold
on most people don't no and that's okay
but if you're coming out and talking
about energy policy and you don't know
anything about it and i'm not going to
pretend to be an expert on this by any
stretch of the imagination but it's
fascinating me i was talking to someone
a long time ago and i said do you know
where electricity comes from and they
went the wall yeah there you go and i
said yeah yeah but like where if i would
like you plug it in the wall it's there
and i was like okay there's like cables
back there right and they're like i
guess you think it's by design where
where does the electricity come from in
that thing and they're like
i don't know
they don't know now to be fair well
that's because they don't know the
history of westinghouse and all the rest
i mean but but so the fascinating thing
is what they don't understand is that
it's it's a flow it's a circuit it has
to keep going the reason they shut down
parts is because it's overloaded and it
can't complete a circuit
so you ask people
what the fascinating thing about energy
is that it's all basically steam power
right even nuclear power it's boiling
water to create steam pressure to spin
it turbine it's kinetic energy yeah it's
reactive converts kinetic energy large
rotating magnets to create electrical
current which then the current flows
through the grid
they don't understand why we can't have
wind and solar be like our permanent
solutions yeah and it's one of the great
evils that the green movement does
is that you take an a coal power plant
that creates uh 900 megawatts of coal
power you take a natural gas power plant
same idea nuclear plant 4 000 megawatts
of power right they will say well if we
build 4 000 acres of solar
we'll get the same capacity it's like
but there's a huge variable that means
it has to consistently shine the sun
non-stop with no cloud cover with no
that is a variable or
massive acreages of underground
batteries which is insane which is not
possible
and not not to mention that who does
this actually benefit you know this
whole idea of the green new deal or
these renewable energy sources only
promotes china economics i mean they
control 15 of the 16 rare mineral mines
in the world they are where we're going
to get a lot of our solar you know
panels and all these different things
with a lithium that's necessary
especially as joe biden in the botched
afghan withdrawal just gave 1.2 trillion
dollars in
lithium mines from afghanistan to the
chinese so the whole life point is is
that why are we continuing to promote
and benefit
our adversarial nations and dependency
upon them as opposed to getting back to
energy independence here in america and
going back to an america first agenda
which is where we need to be as a nation
if they were just honest
you know uh yeah
i'd i'd say okay if they came out and
said oh yeah we know 60 million people
will die overnight when we enact this
policy i'd be like well at least they're
telling you what they're doing and if
you vote for at least you know what
you're voting for but but a lot of
people who are listening to these insane
policies don't know that they're voting
for their way of life to be done yeah
and so so we saw this in denver
people couldn't change their thermostats
you saw that one it's unbelievable they
they 22 000 people they opted in though
yes that's what they said so here's how
it goes because this is actually what
happened it's gonna happen more and more
when you sign up for your electric
company or whatever
they say would you like to sign up for
our energy saver program it's a hundred
dollars off your bill per year they go
wow 100 off per year i'll sign up for
energy say they don't read it then one
day it's 99 degrees outside and the
thermostat says energy saver mode
activated and you can't change it
and they say why can't i change my
thermostat and say well you opted in
maybe you should opt out but we gave you
a free we gave you a cheap deal because
you were willing to do this
so that's that's that's the bit that i
um
i did on twitter where i said absolutely
right i saw that was you're 100 right
it's 99 degrees you go to set your
thermostat with your locked out
governor's orders he declared an
emergency so he decided you know what
i'll go take a drive you go to your
electric vehicle but the screen says no
charge available car wasn't charging
sorry governor's orders governors so he
decided to walk down to the park and
just go and get some fresh air but the
checkpoint down there that the tweet was
limited but there's a guy saying sir if
you want to walk past me you've got to
scan your qr code on your phone and
you're like i can't my phone's dead i
can't use the electricity i'm sorry sir
with no qr code then they tase you
because that's where the electricity
goes then you go home back to your pod
where you grab a bag of crickets to
snack on and wait for the temperature to
go down yeah i think that that is the
future you joke but that is the future
this
if the democrats and the liberals
continue in the path that they're trying
to which is destroying us economically
politically militarily that's actually a
real life scenario that could occur look
at california right now robbing
blackouts i can't say this with any more
sincerity and i know people can think
i'm crazy it is a huge mistake to buy
any sort of smart thermostat a nest any
of those things
if you need if you're like i need to be
able to control it with my phone then
then have a kid and tell the kid go go
lower the thermos
that's why god invented children
this is like the old days when you'd be
like all right i need to change the
television channel go up there
i uh
buy mechanical cars
yeah so you know because i have a tesla
and everybody's like asking me like you
really bought one of those things like
why
and i'm like it's electric car i wanted
to have it as an option and they're like
yeah but you realize we're getting close
to the point where like in california
they ordered people not to know
still i believe right now they can't
charge their cars yeah so what do you do
you can't
look they have these cars i think this
is where i go back to sustainability
right i mean i have a generac generator
at home and but in both of our houses we
have a generac generator just in case i
do have a solar backup just in case but
not on my roof what i use it for is i've
got these kind of lithium ion like
storage uh that i can actually utilize
solar to charge off of it it's for
traveling you know when my family goes
camping or we go out for a sustained
period of time etc but these are areas
that i can you know it tells me i have
this much time i could run my
refrigerator off of it this much this
many times i can charge a computer or a
phone or etc and obviously you can kind
of do it wherever you want but my whole
point is is that i don't utilize that as
my idea of a main source of energy i
utilize it as a backup source of energy
just in the event of a storm or things
like this so i've called for
whistleblowers i'll do it again uh the
left you have to admire their solidarity
with each other right there aren't a lot
of whistleblowers there's no alissa
farah whatever the former trump
spokeswoman who's now on the view who's
just on a tirade about how much she
hates trump most disloyal benedict
arnold etcetera but the left doesn't do
that but i will renew my call for a
whistleblower so i'd love to know what
the governor mansion in california is
right now i'd love to know if paul
pelosi is charging his electric course
i'd love to know if dianne feinstein's
house is literally set at 79. because
that is the orders and the end the
answer is of course they're not none of
their offices are set at below 79. none
of them have off unnecessary lights but
we saw the same thing though with
governor whitmer right we saw it in
michigan whenever nobody's allowed to
take their boats out yet her husband's
allowed to again this is that two-tiered
elitist justice system that i talk about
that i can't stand that we have to break
the mold on where political elitists and
celebrities can act with impunity and
the rest of americans basically get
tossed under the bus but if you thought
it was that angering that you were in
lockdown and nancy pelosi was able to
get her a haircut or you were in
lockdown and the governor of michigan
michelle lujan grisham opened up a store
for her personality that's not expected
no but if that upsets you that that that
that hypocrisy just wait until the end
upsets me hang on hang on wait until the
energy hypocrisy kicks in that you are
not allowed to use electricity today but
the governor's mansion is totally lit up
you are not allowed to charge it on
tesla but i can charge mine why well
because i'm the senior senator from
california but this is the same idea and
hypocrisy is going this hypocrisy though
is exactly what frustrates me about
politicians because
we actually will hold your feet over the
fire if you're doing or committing
insider trading but yet we're allowing
politicians their wives and their
offices to buy selling trade stocks that
they know they're going to pass
legislation on they know they're going
to directly manipulate why has that not
been cut off by the left or the right
this isn't even a republican verse
democrat or a socialist first communist
you know or communist situation this
this is literally just a right versus
wrong a good versus bad the left
populous and the right populist degree
on that point that's the establishment
politicians who are like no no no no
you're not taking away our insider
church i did really well last year my
portfolio was fantastic only because of
my you know my my top secret security
clearance and then the skiff
is getting right now winners mean
imagine deep diving and who bought
pfizer moderna and johnson and johnson
before they made this your decision
imagine looking at the ideas of this
renewable energy and who's bought into
tesla and all the others my point is is
that just like we need to stop a
two-tiered justice system we need to
stop the insider trading and the fact
that our politicians and our celebrities
are able to act in a way that the rest
of america doesn't and we are the
majority as americans the funny thing
about faiza moderna was that weird
speech that biden gave yesterday where
he was screaming i beat pharma
i beat pharma and he's yelling and
you're like beat pharma have you seen
their profits this year
pfizer was like please please lord beat
me again beat me harder daddy like i
beat pharma oh my gosh modern and pfizer
had had a great what did he mean when he
was saying that no one knows what he
would what does he what happened
what does john i don't know what
just a general question what does he
mean and i was thinking on the way over
we're getting to the campaign season
that useless politicians and that does
not include you because you're not a
politician i'm never going to be a
politician the useless politicians will
start saying all these things like i've
stood up to special interests and i've
taken on the big guys and i've fought
for kids and like all these vagaries and
that's what you'll buy in this whole
speech i've i took on pharma and i beat
pharma what the hell does that mean and
no one will ask let me know when you
figure nope no one will you know
donald trump that's who took on pharma
you know when you talk about not taking
special interest groups when you talk
about taking on big pharma when you talk
about holding adversaries accountable
when you talk about proper foreign
policy and a more american first agenda
you can get as mad as you want
about his tweets but no one did greater
than president donald trump can you
really take on farmer though if you
haven't screamed it from a podium he
just gave us with a weird red backdrop
behind you he just gave us fi he gave
pfizer like uh a blank check that's
exactly right but how is that doing good
against pharma that's what he's lying we
get it no no no biden but i'm talking
about you said donald trump was the best
to take in on big pharma but he gave
pfizer a blank check during the pandemic
he also didn't well he actually just
helped to do the research for i mean the
blank check if anything was on operation
warp speed which is just trying to get a
vaccination in play but what i'm talking
about is when he started actually
holding the pharmaceutical companies
accountable and saying that why is it
that all these other nations pay a half
or a third of the price of america when
we're one of the largest consumers we
need the lowest drug rates we need the
lowest drug prices we need to you know
go after what farm is doing by abusing
their rights here in america just
because we can afford to pay more
doesn't mean that we should pay more
that's holding them accountable can you
open up competition for 20 medicines
coming from canada canada yeah correct
and uh
for some reason engineering brands and
all right i've got
they they hated him they flipped out and
they demanded that he be removed and now
you get big big business biden and his
illicit dealings to come back in it's
it's remarkable for the big guy i've got
to know about electricity we before we
move on to the next story because we're
talking about currency and i think
electricity is going to be a currency of
the future how you transport energy is
everything yeah electrical currency it's
an actual phrase um
so like you were saying people don't
know what electricity is a lot of people
why that's by design because we didn't
teach kids in school how to make an
electrical current that's probably by
design too because if you give people
the power to create their own
electricity you lose control of them so
the government's in a position now where
they're like what do we do are we going
to give people the power or are we going
to try and hold on to it as society
falls around us and if people did have
the power and everyone in the world had
equal power to the government would it
just be a constant state of evolution
and fighting and destroying and the
strong man comes up with the with the
techno so like is it good that people
don't have that power we've all seen you
know on youtube perpetual motion yeah
all those videos where people uh build
perpetual motion machines and generate
free electricity
at face value i'd love everyone has
their own nuclear everyone has their own
power generator everyone has infinite
but what would that it would be until
the strong man's like i'm going to use
my power to destroy that guy and take
his so i have twice as much like
that's the history of humanity is that
that's the strong so is the government
doing the right thing by keeping people
stupid and subservient would it would
the people would it be constant war if
they didn't no i can understand your
point of saying if if the government
supplies the electricity maybe we take
away that potential for conflict between
households or neighborhoods or whatever
and i can understand that but then if
we've given the government that that
power then they also have that
responsibility and they're failing that
responsibility you know a great radio
host who i'm friends with and i go on a
show a lot of jesse kelly out of houston
he was replying on a bunch of tweet
threads saying you don't get to ask me
to reduce my electricity
consumption because your job is not to
tell me how to live my life your job is
to produce electricity and if you're the
governor of california and it is a
numbers game california has to generate
i think it's like something like 52 000
uh
megawatts of electricity a day if you
don't produce that then you're failing
your people and that's all the election
matters about you can talk about the
election is about equity it's about
justice it's about creating a more
tolerant society for california it's
about homeless all that is crap so the
government the election in california
should be on based on the fact that as
governor you are responsible for a few
things crime and boy are you failing
electricity production boy are you
failing and gavin newsom will win
re-election
effortlessly because that is also the
two-tier system that we're dividing into
when one last thing just to finish when
california as tim said they have to
start to shut down segments of the grid
to keep the overall sustainability when
they shut down areas look who they shut
down it will not be silicon valley it
will not be facebook's office it will
not be a kardashian household or malibu
it'll be middle and low income families
voiceless powerless people who have
useless republicans representing them in
congress will get pledged into darkness
and they'll be like this is unfair but
if you live in the central valley and
you go four days without power you pray
to god your congressman fights for you
but obviously your congressman is
probably just going to be like well you
know life sucks guys but i was in dc i
witnessed this personally during the
drought in uh i think it was like 2015 i
went to larry county
poor working families had had no water
golf courses did yeah the city
you know the people with money and they
want no no don't get me wrong it's like
they were doing well they were in a
serious drought they had a lot of water
but they they got the water they needed
and uh
that's that's the reality of it new york
when the power went out what was the
first neighborhood brownsville
which is an all-black neighborhood in
brooklyn uh summer of 2021 last year
when they had to turn off a small
percentage of the grid and bill de
blasio's administration and that's
brownsville in east new york and if you
look at videos of that time the
residents there poor black people are
standing outside because you can't be
inside because the windows don't open in
those housing units but isn't it funny
that these are the exact same people who
say that you owe me your vote even
though i i put you always at the end of
the line you're the one this is why you
talked about earlier at the end of the
day the republican party went from being
the wine and cheese party to the beer
and blue jeans party and that happened
on a donald trump that happened with
president trump and we have to
acknowledge that we now represent the
interests of the people we we now
represent the interest of the everyday
blue-collar modern day society because
why most of us came from that like
myself my grandfather was a welder my
grandmother was a beautician they
adopted me because i lived in a you know
family where my mom and dad had
substance and drug abuse issues were in
and out of prison my entire life and
guess what that's why i fight so hard
for the american people because i am one
of you let me let me jump to the story
this is a story from newsweek and it
helps us understand why it is that uh we
end up with the politicians we end up
with
jennifer lawrence admits to having
nightmares about tucker carlson supposed
to date him okay yeah right she doesn't
she's she's just mad
yeah her interview
this was uh oh that people want to date
her yeah you're just upset because you
want a date look
in vogue's october issue
she said that she has recurring
nightmares she says i can't f with
people who aren't political anymore you
live in the united states of america you
you have to be political it's too dire
politics are killing people
she said that she has nightmares
starring tucker carlson huh okay
these people they're they're they're out
of their minds you know we talked about
you know wild boars guns these are
people who've probably never stepped
foot in a wooded area they've they've
probably never driven outside of a you
know an incorporated town or whatever
been attacked by a raccoon lately what
was the old saying first world issues
yes yeah yeah yeah so my life is so good
let's just google jennifer lawrence net
worth oh yeah let's what is it what is
that net worth
did you get it billions and millions i'm
sure of course it is jennifer lawrence
net worth has averaged at 160 million
dollars i'm sorry for like she's the
victim right now guys we need to
understand that she's the victim in this
and we all need to feel sorry for her
her and megan merkel yeah they're the
real victims right now dreams are funny
carlson net worth 30 million dollars
yeah she's worth what it was like but
just
almost five
yeah more than five times senator
carlson's net worth this is what happens
this is
man
people who are extremely powerful and
wealthy but it's it's the hunger games
it's capital city
which she actually was the main actress
there you go yeah it's ironic isn't it
that she in real life represents the
snooty people drinking ipac to vomit and
keep eating while poor people actually
suffer and their and and it's the funny
thing about the hunger games the movies
i don't know if it's the same thing in
the books
the people in the capital are oblivious
to the suffering of the people outside
for the most part and they're all
weird-looking
oh yeah yeah they're all kind of like
blue hair
blue hair they're all shaved heads
slightly androgynous and and bizarre and
uncomfortable and
she so so the problem is you get someone
like jennifer lawrence and one of the
quotes she has i don't know if it's in
the news week article but she said uh
here we go quote it breaks my heart
because america had the choice between a
woman and a dangerous dangerous jar of
mayonnaise and she said and they were
like well we can't have a woman let's go
with the jar of mayonnaise i don't want
to disparage my family but i know that a
lot of people are in a similar position
with their families how could you raise
a daughter from birth and believe she
doesn't deserve equality how that is not
why donald trump won
i would say the big reason but when it
was a choice between donald trump and
hillary clinton is that i don't know
hillary clinton uh was the clinton
foundation was receiving money from
foreign governments while she was
secretary of state that the the obama
administration got us entangled in a
bunch of wars that hillary clinton said
we came we saw he died
yeah give me that against donald trump
you know what i still didn't vote for
him but then you give me joe biden and
you give me four years of what donald
trump was trying to do and i was like
okay all right
as if
the big issue for me
is that hillary clinton is a woman no
it's that she's a psychopathic she's a
sociopathic murderer
also what they did to bernie sanders was
unconscionable bernie was winning that
election he had all the energy and then
the clinton i don't know what
the dnc basically yeah that was under
donna brazil and if you remember donna
brazile actually was even giving hillary
clinton the questions ahead of time
before the presidential nomination
debates
and she was caught doing this and she
profited massively off of this she gave
hillary the questions when she fought
the debate bernie that's exactly before
he didn't have the questions she that's
insane if you know that how could you
like that's how why did this support it
this is the mentality
that we're up against her vote is equal
to yours daniel so when you vote and she
votes
she's like you just want to vote for
mayonnaise and you're like i have very
serious concerns about how people will
live when there's no energy
you're you hate women you're a racist
this is the new thing you're xenophobe
you know when you don't think exactly
like them they want to name call them we
saw this from the president himself you
know the i call him the selected not
elected president of the united states
but you saw this where that's exactly
what he did he's gone now to name
calling
and telling all of us you know first it
was we're deplorables now we're
extremists just because we care about
our nation and we are you know god
fearing america loving individual
patriots and now all of a sudden we're
labeled as extremists as a result of it
you know we don't think like you we
don't act like you we don't behave like
you therefore you are a racist or a
xenophobe or an extremist you know this
is really where the left has gone and
meanwhile the rest of us who are sitting
as part of maga or sitting as part of
the america first agenda we're just
simply saying well no
we just care about getting back to
constitutionality freedoms liberties the
rights for individuals rights for
individual states the ability for people
to make their own decisions for the
protection of our children the you know
betterment of all of america getting
back to american exceptionalism no no
you're an extremist jennifer lawrence
cares so deeply about women's issues
that she stood next to harvey weinstein
probably did unspeakable things to him
to get ahead in her career and to get
the leading roles that she did as a 16
year old um and watched millions of
dozens of women get abused by harvey
weinstein and well and but but you know
what she cares very very deeply what is
this about women's issues is her
relationship with that guy is that is
that was that was that a big story
that's known absolutely yeah absolutely
i always love how they say we care so
much about women's rights but at the
same time they won't protect or even try
and prevent women's sports from being
taken as a b or a c or a d role for
biologically more men what was the one
winter's bone to uh the the one that was
awful with bradley cooper where
uh gosh the silver linings playbook
she's got a long history with harvey
weinstein and you did not get a leading
role as a lady in a harvey weinstein
film unless
you did the things that harvey weinstein
wanted you to do the article from
newsweek did you get eight hours ago
jennifer lawrence rumors she effed
that's harvey weinstein that's that's
the same interview she did in the in the
university with vogue she said it was
it's not true i'm sure she is no of
course not it's not true of course she's
going to say it's not true you know what
is she going to come out and say it's
truthful well the only reason people are
saying is would i hate women i think
about exactly his rights and black
rights and trans rights i think of like
human rights like it's we're not we
shouldn't be arguing about who gets the
better bedroom in the slave quarters it
should be about let's not be slaves
people it doesn't matter who you are
that's a great line that was great
that's a very good line
yeah i just i i am sick and tired of of
people
glomming on to whatever they think their
unique qualifier is that makes them a
victim when they are the most privileged
who in the world has more privilege than
jennifer lawrence if we lined up all
330 million americans in privileged
order where do you think jennifer
lawrence ranks does she rank i mean
you're definitely higher than i am but
60 million dollars but let me think
about it this idea of self victimization
is what the left has gone to and it's
the same with meghan markle who gave
another interview yesterday about how
hard her life is the little princess
right this nonsense that we're always
victims because victimhood is very very
sellable to correct you i think she's a
duchess that's just but i mean at what
point at what point you've won an oscar
and you're worth 160 million dollars
seriously at what point can you just
shut the hell up and say you know what
my life's been great but look oh yeah
this happens all the time though i mean
look at your actual
deal look you got athletes and you've
got people who have who've gone to the
ranks of political elites who want to
talk about how there's this systemic
racism that exists and there's this you
know glass ceiling that's
wait a second you're one of the leading
figures whether it's in politics or
whether it's in you know celebrity you
know status
how did that glass ceiling impact you
how how did that systemic racism prevent
you from becoming the vice president of
the united states or how did that
prevent you from becoming one of the
wealthiest talk show hosts in the world
or one of the wealthiest you know
basketball players but yet you want to
talk about how you're so disenfranchised
because the real victims in society
don't have a voice and it is the job of
a justice society to elevate those
people like what i was just saying about
electricity the most abused people in
the green blackouts are going to be
people who are voiceless and powerless
and no one will stand up for them the
most abused people clearly are
celebrities worth
ten figures
they've been treated so horrible yeah
yeah and joe biden ask him he'll always
tell you how hard his life was he and
eighty percent of his friends all have
cancer right he'll tell you what
wraps up her day of work where she's
pretending to be somebody else granted
she's good at it good for her
she wraps up her day at work and then
probably hangs out in an infinity pool
with like rare imported escargot or
other nonsense like
160 million dollar net worth it's good
it's like in that iron iron man 2 when
justin hammer the bad guy is eating the
the dessert and he's like it's italian i
have it imported every day or whatever
it's like yeah okay well that sounds
like nancy pelosi when she was talking
about you know how disenfranchised she
was while she sat in front of what was
it like thirty dollar pints of ice cream
behind her thirty thousand dollars i
know everyone's suffering but i've got
thirty dollar ice cream in my freezer i
will say this i've had that ice cream
once in my life and it is really really
really good but it is like 15 for a
little tiny thing it was remarkably good
but who i can't afford it i can't afford
it on the regular and she opened up her
drawer by the way her sub-zero was
twenty thousand dollars and she had two
side by side and she opened up her
freezer drawer and she had probably
about
two hundred dollars worth of ice cream
in her in her twenty-five hours i'm sure
if you would open up the main one it
would have been nothing but like vodka
because we all know that she's like
perpetually drunk it's it's fascinating
to me
that there are uh
joe biden the democrats come out and
they're like republicans are just mad
the irs agents are going to go after
billionaires it's like dude 87 000
agents aren't needed to go after like
500 billion yes around 479 or so and if
you're gonna go after millionaires i
think this was like 30 000 or something
like that right yeah you still don't
need that many irs agents one irs agent
can handle multiple people
but again though i go back to the idea
which is that okay if you're there to
audit me i understand if you're trying
to say all right i need calculators and
ink cartridges and things like that but
why do i need six hundred thousand
dollars in small calorie ammunition why
do i need a roles and responsibility
that says i need to be able to issue
deadly force i need to go ahead and be
able to detain search warrants etc this
is deep state police force being done
and i'll tell you something the average
american is not coming to me and my
constituents by the way are not coming
to me and saying hey you know what we
really need
we need 87 000 more irs agents you know
what they're saying we need to secure
our borders we need to get our energy
prices under control i need to make sure
that i am protecting my children and the
schools i need to make sure that our
economy and our inflation gets under
control the everyday american
wants affordability and safety they
don't care about getting 87 000 irs
agents and this just shows the tone
death you know self-vilifying you know
effect of of the left and the liberals
that are basically saying no no no you
don't understand in 20 to 30 years this
is going to benefit you the the irs
criminal uh investigative service i
think it's something like that it's been
around for like 100 years
and and but but i think it's important
to point out
a lot of people made it seem like the
buying the bullets was a rare or new
thing that happens all the time and
that's something you all need to pay
attention to
they don't need those bullets for
billionaires
they're not going to jeff bezos's house
with guns
they're going after now to be fair drug
dealers but they're going after people
who uh there was a in one of the
training sessions they did it was a a
guy who owned a landscaping business who
didn't report a lawnmower or something
like that
in that you know that video where
they're like they walk up to a guy and
they'll have the guns and they're doing
the training they're going up to a small
business owner they're not practicing
going after cartels or anything but tim
they've also learned that it's easier to
force you to comply at the end of a
barrel than it is from the end of an ink
pen
and that's what we all need to be
concerned here and i'll tell you
something i mean going back
i i think in 1913 it was probably one of
the worst years for our constitution
because one we had the 16th amendment
which was federal income taxes and the
17th amendment which actually you know
stopped our u.s senators from actually
being elected by our state legislators
which actually controlled federal
overgrowth in the violations of our 10th
amendment but you know i'm one of those
guys that why should i be taxed on the
the hard work that i've you know earned
or the investments why couldn't it be on
consumer and fair tax why can't we go to
something like this which actually makes
sense for every individual but not only
this why can't we reduce federal
government you know when it comes to the
irs or the atf or the doe or any of
these and that's the department of
education by the way not energy but my
whole point you can reduce energy better
but my whole point is that federal
overgrowth
and the weaponization
of these departments and agencies
will be the death of america the 87 000
agents are going to do so much damage to
the daily commerce that we do as a
country uh it it is not strange and
venmo was was very convenient for just
getting rid of like checks and paper and
cash but it was not hard to to bring you
know x number ahead of cattle and swap
forty thousand dollars and i'll keep
that 40 grand in my venmo because i know
tomorrow i'm gonna do it on so and i
don't really have the 40 000. i'm
holding it for a little while until i
get the cows back from auction and then
the venmo but if i have irs agents
they're gonna be like what was this
forty thousand dollar and that's exactly
what but i wasn't six hundred dollars
what's this 40 what's this four thousand
dollars you have on venmo well it wasn't
really a profit it was a tim it was a
transaction that was taking two weeks
and it's going to disappear doesn't
matter where your taxes are they they
tried implementing that policy or that
that law about tracking 600 dollar
transactions or more i'm referring to
that yeah they're not going after
billionaires dude correct well we
already know that 75
of last year's audits were people that
was making less than a hundred grand a
year so the idea that they're getting
these 87 000
you know irs agents
it's it baffles my mind when i think
about the fact of what that costs and
why we're not allocating that money to
things like securing our borders or
increasing our law enforcement so we can
get increased criminality under control
or the fact that we're 12 to 15 000
recruitment short for our armed services
why aren't we looking at things that
actually matter to the everyday american
and the reason why
because the government wants to steal
every every penny they have out of your
pocket i think they it's a con it's a
slow motion demolition i mean they're
just this is the the military for
instance the recruitment no who wants to
join a woke military no one does they're
worried about pronouns crt inclusiveness
diversity instead of the things they
need to be worried about which is
increased lethality readiness and
preparedness you know that's the things
that i focused on when i was in the
military yeah but if you're one of these
people who like that woman from the
guardian article who's like i would
never survive she's the kind of person
running the military these days yeah and
so that's exactly right i mean
look who's running the nuclear sector
right now i mean i i don't even know
what its name is
no is anyone running it oh well
probably not let's let's i want to jump
to the store from the post of money
we can't finish with jennifer lawrence
the poor girl she never gets any time to
she needs to be there
from the post millennial
majority of americans say biden's
anti-maga speech was designed to incite
conflict the poll found that 56.8
percent of likely general election
voters said that biden's speech
represents a dangerous escalation in
rhetoric and is designed to incite
conflict amongst americans the babylon
bees had their best night ever
they're like 30 biden kicked out of
austrian art school yeah biden issues
non-aggression pact with poland i
genuinely spit out laughing when i saw
that headline pop up um yeah it was a cr
i had to watch that speech because i did
a bunch of radio and tv on it later on
that night and
that was just some crazy comes out
and he's like i'm the president and i
hate half this country
and then the next day they're like why
were you talking about trump supporters
that was like
i was not talking about trump supporters
then he comes out and like the policies
proposed by these people are a threat
dude
it is
that people fall for this or they lie is
it is it is insane pandering to the base
is gutting the democrats and that's it
it's backfiring already 56.8 percent
they don't like it independent voters
they don't like it
you're not going to win with just
getting democrats you've got to sell and
especially when you ran as being the
unifier and you became the
divider-in-chief i mean that's really
what's taken place here and so we have
to understand the fact that what they're
looking at and when you're seeing
headlines like this where they're
thinking oh this is to incite conflict
well that's because they thought that
the whole january 6th incident was
actually good for them politically and
they're trying to you know basically
utilize that to try and advance them and
you know stop the red wave from coming
in but you know look we have to identify
for what it is i mean this is literally
him calling half of the nation extremist
you know what that speech reminded me of
you know like and especially in 80s or
early 90s movie where there's some bad
thing happening and finally someone
stands up in the high school gym and
they give this speech and all the bad
guys put their head down and realize
they're wrong and then finally someone
courageously starts this little crap
clap and everyone's like yes and justice
is served that speech to me sounds like
it was written by a 26 year old kid who
was a poli sci major who really thinks
that if i just lay it out like this all
those trump supporters are going to sit
there at home and say you know what guys
i think they're right i think like it
was written by a child but they didn't
identify
but they never did actually
say
what it was that we as america's first
candidates actually ordered americans
sorry
are actually about they didn't identify
i mean the people they described was
their own followers well and the thing
that cracked me up is that after the
speech of of calling us all these names
was one of his last lines was how we
have to start seeing each other as
fellow americans and i thought did you
just not listen to the things you read
off the teleprompter for the last 20
minutes like it really was whoever his
speech writers are and boy this white
house has struggled with speech writers
none more than kamalas of course um
but but it really was a ch it was a very
immature speech it sounded like that
speech that a kid wants to give to their
mom because mom didn't let me that it it
was just a childish immature petty
petulant speech it was embarrassing
quite frankly was it written i didn't
see him reading off a prompter or any
note oh there's no way that he rambled
on that long without no absolutely
multiple monitors around the room a lot
of times they have these see-through
monitors that are at a distance you
can't see because of the camera angles
and they're looking at the back shots
but he's sitting here when he's going
left to right it's because there's
usually two prompters that are up there
that are clear that actually have
everything out there do you really think
he can't joe biden could keep a
continuous thought for more than 30
seconds where he says vanilla or
chocolate ice cream remember i don't
think so remember maybe if he's on the
show shaking hands remember the simpsons
episode where homer is like you have my
undivided attention and then it zooms
into his brain and it's like a turtle
playing like old macdonald or whatever
like banging on his chest that's what i
imagined if i'd taken this poll here i
would have said that it seemed like the
speech was intended to divide an insight
maybe i don't have inside conflict
divide because of the red background
correct blood red background you see the
wide shot there's also all this blue and
there's just this little segment but all
the the media apparatus that wanted to
record it had just pure red one
can i just
say i just say one thing though whether
it's republican or democrat
one of the things that disgusts me
as you know prior military and you know
comment veteran
we have to stop utilizing our military
for backdrop props
you know this is something that just
shows absolute disrespect because the
thing that you have to understand is is
that when you serve in the military you
serve a commander-in-chief and we don't
think of this as it isn't a political
thing for us
and the fact that each the left and the
right trying to utilize the military as
a political backdrop really needs to
stop i think it's illegal to to a
campaign with military present is that
someone else it's a violation of
campaign rules that military uh and also
like even police and fire in the in
their uniform they're not they're not
allowed but not the personal capacity
president is allowed to the president
vice president are allowed to campaign
if the military can't do politics yes
but that's why they said this was not a
campaign speech this was a presidential
speech again deep concern for fossil
fuel use we had to fly to philadelphia
no fossil fuels to light up independence
hall right why couldn't he given the
speech from the oval right i don't know
why and this is something i've asked
before in other shows
ever since reagan really and maybe a
little bit clinton presidents don't use
the oval anymore right ronald reagan
addressed everyone from the oval on the
regular when he gave a speech and i
don't know why what's changed but
presidents don't speak is there a more
presidential backdrop joe biden than the
resolute desk joe biden had a sound
stage built
they have that weird that that weird
room yeah um where they do
why do you need a fake prize well i
think that one that one was obvious
because it was the back window was a tv
screen
and so they could pre-record what they
needed to to send it out so they didn't
have to worry about biden you know but
president trump though president trump
did
i i would say 90 unless he was actually
on an official delegation or a visit or
anything like that i mean he did it from
the rose garden or he did it from the
white house yeah he liked the east room
very much and he liked the rose garden
but i just i'm always fascinated that we
don't do more things he did obviously
there's always like diplomats etcetera
um
and pressers uh
that's what this is for for the bite
administration it's about political
rhetoric theatrics and and trying to you
know
assuage every other american from
looking at what's really going on in
america yeah and this was obviously
produced you know there are there are
advanced teams that put these together
josh if you're still watching he paid
for most of them right i mean i know
people who do this for maybe jennifer
lawrence
on her part time well someone had to
decide this is the backdrop imagine if
independence hall was just lit up bright
white and just light and just light and
he gave out and he said you know the
constitution was written here and we are
one america and i know we have a lot of
division but we can come together and
stop the division and and i want to hear
from you
he could have given a speech that even
his greatest detractors would say
i hate the guy but you know what i i
can't disagree with that speech who
orchestrated this to say like this is
the backdrop this is the rhetoric this
is the tone this is the clenched fist
but according to according to the left
though they said that biden has been too
soft and too polite and too nice and
he's again to to quote something that
tim talked about earlier which is that
this is pandering to the left this is
continuing to try and go ahead and buy
into this rhetoric that this is somehow
going to prevent a red wave and actually
if he would have gone with the idea that
you had
that would have probably actually swayed
more npas to the left than it would have
actually pushed him to the right so
independence two to one that's that's if
you are running his campaign right now
that
he could have came out that keeps you up
at night the way jennifer lawrence has
tucker carlson nightmares independent
voters are you know i think if he had
come out well people disagree
if he had come out he'd pardoned january
6 supporters
the left would be forced to agree with
him you you laugh but that's actually
not that that's actually a great idea
the idea of him doing it i love the idea
it should have happened if you want to
talk about being a unifier and again
stop trying to look at the political
imprisonment of these individuals like
jeremy brown who's in pinellas county
jail who still has no charges levied
against him former special forces former
ranger who literally has no charges
levied against him and never entered the
capital but has been in prison this
entire time i mean
these are the types of people that we
need to be fighting for i could say this
without hesitation if joe biden came out
and pardoned all the people from january
6
and he called for an end to the hearings
and said we have to move past it he
would guarantee his re-election until
when he pardoned someone is it a general
pardon like i pardon you for every crime
you've ever committed no just for the
one specific but that is it so right
not just expunged from the record you
know at any level of the judiciary no
one can bring up charges no one can
that's it it is done they would lose the
the far left and the hard left they
would the moderates they'd gain the
moderates would be like like the you
know the more establishment crony
democrat types would be like aren't we
so noble and compassionate magnanimous
yeah and then the far left would be like
we just want a revolution and you're
hurting that by doing this and cnn would
run to the to the mitt romneys of the
world and get them to admit what a great
guy he is and like see even republicans
admit that he is a great and it would
guarantee his re-election
would have actually have gone towards
his claim
of being the united states election
though no it would kind of
economics energy rolling blackouts i
don't know about that
that's that that is true i think we're
just talking about what would have
potentially have been a lot better which
anything a rerun of the simpsons would
have been better than this right here
it's like the the
the military the marines come out they
play the song and then they wheel out a
tv and just put a tv up and it plays an
episode of the simpsons and and that
would have probably had a better rating
than this this felt like if you approve
of the rerun of the simpsons biden
played actually well
yeah we all really enjoyed it they were
like anticipating if all of the economy
is crumbling as in like okay we're going
to need to blame somebody in the future
so let's plant the seeds now
they've done the mag stuff as the seeds
are planted now if [ __ ] really hits the
fan we got a villain that we can pin it
on um it's very nazi germany what they
do with the jews that's what it felt
like to me it is and and when you have
40-year high record inflation when you
have 40-year high uh 30-year high energy
prices when you have you're threatening
to disarm americans you are literally in
a recession regardless of how we
determine the new definition is we are
literally in a recession when you look
at all the economic indicators
of the suffering the american families
and and blue collar and working-class
americans are feeling um there is no
reason why this guy should should be in
office so what do you do
you find a scapegoat and if it's if it
was it was the jews in nazi germany and
now it's the magga you're absolutely
right because i can't run on the fact
that that that oil prices and energy
prices and food prices are at record
high and talking about the upcoming
depression they're going to get much
much worse because winter hasn't even
kicked in yet we haven't even harvested
the wheat yet let's jump to the story
from usa9
coy griffin barred from public office
for insect insurrectionary conduct a new
mexico judge ruled cory griffin was
disqualified from holding office under
section 3 of the 14th amendment so they
finally got one
they have been trying democrats to get
people barred from holding office under
the 14th amendment for being insurrect
for for insurrection and now a judge has
actually done it
is barring him from office i think
they're removing him right
in a judgment issued tuesday tuesday
morning new mexico district court judge
francis j matthew ruled griffin was
permanently enjoined and prohibited from
seeking or holding any federal or state
position as defined by the 14th
amendment to the u.s constitution that
includes his current position as a
commissioner in otero county new mexico
the judge wrote this is crazy stuff well
this had nothing to do and again i think
they need to understand what
insurrection actually means but
go back to what he actually did he was
the founder of cowboys for trump
and that's really what this is about
this is continual witch hunt and going
after trump trump trump maga maga
you're seeing this in every single thing
that's playing out and it's really about
what president trump told us a long time
ago which is that they're not after me
they're after you i'm just in the way
yep
this is i i i don't know if this will be
upheld i mean i imagine that'll get
appealed as it should yeah but the idea
that they keep levying these attacks i'm
just like guys guys
civil war
come on
come on they're not trying to win
elections now with stuff like this
they're just trying to find a judge
who's willing to bang a gavel and say
okay fine we removed him they tried
doing it to marjorie taylor green that's
right they uh they tried doing it to uh
madison cawthorne who else did they go
after on this one obviously well and
they were successful with the
establishment's help of eliminating
madison but that was through the primary
100 they primated them out i'm talking
about
when you can't even win a primary they
go to a judge and say just bang your
gavel and say he can't be in office and
the judge went okay they used to do that
and seize people's property then there
were rebellions and revolts that shay's
rebellion was about them seizing their
land
i don't know
also taking away their ability to run
for office
man it doesn't feel right so i'll tell
you one of the things that i i probably
have people who disagree with me on this
but you know it's like i talk about you
know my my mom and dad they both have
you know a very colorful past and and
they've committed mistakes and and
they're they've have felony because of
drug use and and all the other things
like this but
you know denying people who are felons
from their right to vote you're
essentially eliminating their voice and
and i just don't agree with this you
know it's like the idea that you know i
have two children i have a seventeen and
seven year old and you know it's like my
seven-year-old doing something wrong and
then after i i give him his punishment
me carrying that for the rest of his
life i mean that's really what it feels
like and you know this is the type of
thing that i just really push back
against
where you're continually you know
basically levied as a criminal as a
result of a single crime no matter what
your actual punishment was and the
elimination of your voice or the banging
of a gavel ending your capabilities to
serve our nation i mean
at some stage this really we have to
start looking at our justice system and
how that works can they stop people from
running for local elections too with
this stuff that's
it is a local election that's what this
is an outside commission
for like a federal force or a state
governance force to tell you you can't
govern and your local community is way
antithetical to the united states in new
mexico it's un-american i mean it truly
is un-american i mean the idea that one
if you commit a crime you can never vote
again you can never have a voice again
you can you know with a bang of a gavel
you can never ever serve in office again
i mean this is
the is the the issue is
this was a a really stupid article in
the section in the in the 14th amendment
because it was obvious and i suppose the
founding fathers of the foresight but
you know 80 years later they did not so
much it's obvious that
how do you define insurrection against
the government yeah right george
washington waged an insurrection against
the king the point is happy insurrection
it's january 6 in insurrection the the
feds look there's some people who are
currently charged with seditious
conspiracy i really don't believe but
you know the funniest part do you know
who the people who are indicted are
people like john earl sullivan who is a
very well-known blm antagonist who
basically raised a a false flag
he did have an indictment he did yes he
did oh wow and they did nothing with it
this is the same guy by the way that cnn
paid for the murder of ashley babbitt's
you know footage he was indicted for
january for being on there in the
capital correct and and he was actually
in a false flight operation wearing all
maggot gear even though he's a blm
antagonist i mean this this is
we we have to really start understanding
either we're moving past this or we're
going to do a proper not this nonsense
j6 unselect committee where they
wouldn't even allow true patriots in a
bipartisan fashion like congressman jim
jordan or congressman jim banks to sit
on this you know they picked the other
two democrats kenzinger and cheney who
are both gone now but but the whole
point is is that you know we need proper
justice you know we need real
investigations you know there is no
doubt in my mind that there's a false
flag operation there's no doubt in my
mind that there was some type of an fbi
kind of insider you know deal going on
here i mean we
we have to start looking at this and
really investigate if we're going to
investigate this investigate the real
way not from a partisan political witch
hunt but from a real we want to get the
answers you got to win
but you and that's partisan publicly got
to win in november
and then not only do they have to win
but you have to win leverage over the
you know establishment republican types
who are going to just sit on their hands
and go well hold up now
well you know what's funny about this
case compared to
someone else so this guy this will stick
with him forever can't run for office
he's an insurrectionist but if you were
in kenosha that night and you burnt down
15 stores and you looted stuff and you
you could run for office and you can
just say you were out there probably
this is exactly what i talked about you
were a protester at that because you
believe deeply in these issues and black
lives matter itself it's mostly peaceful
protest yeah and so so one guy is is an
insurrectionist and who walked through
the capitol building again obeying those
red velvet ropes we talked to the uh
podium guy
i know he's a lectern that was great but
everyone calls him podium guy and his
story it's like he's a dude who walked
into a building befuddled and kind of
ignorantly and then moved a thing and
went to prison for it meanwhile you have
people who romped about set fire to
buildings throw brick throw brick
through murdered david dorn who was the
former uh uh law enforcement
guy though well they did but my point is
though is that at the exact same time
that seattle minneapolis new york
portland you had chop you had all these
things going on which were complete
lawlessness violent rioting looting of
of tens of millions of dollars if not
more murders rapes all these things were
going on they justified those as
protests you had the left who were
inciting this saying like maxwell maxine
waters who was saying well you should
get in the face of every single one of
your political opponents or you know you
have the others the vice president
herself who actually created the
minneapolis you know foundation fund or
whatever that was the bail fund
i mean the idea that they're actually
promoting this
you know and then all of a sudden they
want to go ahead and just because it's
conservatives on one side or or
democrats on the other they want to go
ahead and try and re-label this or re
you know identify this this this is the
type of thing that america doesn't need
yeah one of the things that also
bothered me about the biden speech just
connecting the two for a second was the
amount of uh the straw men and i i
firmly believe that straw men
are an essential tool of the democrat
party but multiple times he kept talking
about how these maga people who were
calling for political violence i've
never heard for anyone except for maxine
waters i've never heard anyone call for
i've never i've listened to a lot of
trump speeches i follow a lot of these
folks i do this this stuff for a living
i i'm trying to find someone who has
called for political violence and yet he
gave that that remark so comfortably so
callously that many of these maga
republicans and then he went on
fantastic terrorism there is no use for
for
there is no time ever for political
violence and everyone collapsed the left
says and even said go home peacefully
who the left says donald trump speaking
out in the way he does is stochastic
terrorism yeah that was my favorite what
that means is
that when trump says i think this thing
is a bad thing
he's secretly calling on his followers
to go and attack that exactly when joe
biden comes out and says they're
extremists a threat to our country and
they embrace violence what would you
call that but this goes back to the old
idea that remember when the king
he actually comes forward and says can
no one rid me of this petulant priest
and all of a sudden they go out and
murder the priest and say oh well you
are actually the reasoning for this
because you actually indirectly said
this right this is what they're trying
to refer to and they try and say this
about president trump but president
trump wasn't indirectly hinting at
anything he very clearly said
let us all go home peacefully but i
don't mean i don't mean that speech i'm
talking about in general yeah no i i'm
with you i'm just trying to say that i
think that's what the left is trying to
say though is that he somehow you know
made this into charles manson for
instance he told his followers go eth it
up go mess them up you know to the and
then they went and they killed people
manson never said go kill people he just
said go mess it up trump didn't say go
mess it up no he didn't and tell them to
go hurt anything you sit in the side
he was pretty specific about it being
peaceful too correct i just don't
understand and i also just again i have
a great dislike for the establishment
media i just find it funny that he makes
those straw men comments so comfortably
and yet no one
seems curious to say well mr president
could you give us an example of who is
calling for political that is a very
good and basic question the next time he
ever speaks to the media we're going on
220 days where he hasn't spoken to the
media but that is a great question you
decried mega republicans uh um um
calling for political violence could you
cite an example of a mag of republican
calling for political revival
of course not but no one will ever ask
him that question they will ask him like
mr president when you're eating vanilla
ice cream how does that make your tummy
feel how do you ask
the president right now the office has
no responsibility to reply to any
questions man come on which is a problem
well he doesn't take questions and
that's the whole point he goes up there
he reads from teleprompters as his
handlers tell him and then he shuffles
off and and you know mysteriously shakes
hands of people who don't actually exist
i got i got some questions so so you're
likely you're coming into congress right
you won the primary that's basically the
race it's an r plus district so you you
got it you think right well i don't take
anything for granted but yes i i it oh
god
politician listen to that
i just don't believe you're taking my
phone
i'm joking so uh
it would be the first time you you've
held you'd hold federal office i've
never run in my life what do you what do
you what do you want to do what do you
think you can do once you get in well i
want to bring awareness to the real
issues i want to actually bring real
solutions to things i want to understand
the fact that the america first agenda
doesn't make you a racist or a xenophobe
when you just want to secure your
borders protect your children you know
get our military back to its original
strength stop these endless wars stop
looking at the insider trading that's
going on within politics call balls and
strikes on both sides i mean look we
have to understand that the deep state
and swamp you know whether that's left
or right are all involved and we know
this we have to stop the corruption we
have to actually identify what the
corruption is that's why you know in
mind very much like president trump like
i'm donating 100 of my salary back into
my actual district selected by my
constituents to a woman child or veteran
charity the other thing is that myself
my wife and anyone who wants to work in
my office cannot buy selling trade
stocks while we're in office this is not
about political enrichment this is about
serving the people and no one
understands about serving the people
more than the actual military who went
out was willing to die when they swore
that oath and our oath doesn't expire
just because we take off that uniform
you know this is really about making
sure that we get back to what it is to
be a true constitutionalist be a true
conservative understand physical
responsibility
understand the significance of energy
independence and knowing that we cannot
you know i'm a business owner i am about
job creation and guess what government
doesn't create jobs they stifle they
over regulate and they actually prevent
jobs we need to empower the private
sector we need to understand the 10th
amendment in understanding state and
individual rights these are the things
that i stand for and at the end of the
day i'm an employee of the seventh
district of florida i am not the one who
gets elected by the people and then
thinks that the party somehow put me in
office
so i'm all about and i and i have a
couple of bills that i want to pass in
my first hundred days and one of the
bills that i really like is called the
publishing house bill
one of the things i want to look at is
that i don't believe in impeding upon
state rights and governor ron desantis
has done the k through right parental
rights bill which i think is phenomenal
but i think from a federal issue one of
the things that we should be looking at
holding the publishing houses
accountable like the mcgraw-hills or
anyone else who is intentionally
publishing pornographic or inappropriate
material with the intent of distribution
to underage inappropriate material to
children that are the age of six and
seven years old we also need to start
thinking about the days when i grew up
where if i went to my grandmother would
drop me off to the movies and give me 20
and i'd have to go in and they'd say how
old are you oh i'm 13. okay here's the
movies that you can buy and here's the
ratings why can't we put books that have
actual ratings on it a g rating a pg-13
rating etc so that our parents who work
all day long who don't have time to
proofread all these books can go ahead
and say you know what this is within
your age group now i'm not saying we
should ban books you can publish as many
books as you want
but i'm saying that you should not and
cannot basically distribute these to an
actual under underage or youth in our
library and if you do it should be a
felonious offense you should register as
a sex predator for the rest of your life
are you talking about imagery or are you
talking about both descriptors so i i it
doesn't matter even if you try and make
it an anime or you're trying to get a
cartoon i mean look at genderqueer for
example which actually shows oral sex
and that's supposed to be third grade
appropriate if they're describing it
that would be
like you don't want like even textual
descriptions but my whole point is that
whether you actually write it in text or
you actually show it in you know the
figure it's the exact same thing so my
question is uh there are parts of the
bible that are explicit and talk about
sex
should that be restricted from schools
but having they already banned the bible
from from being in schools i mean i had
a young kid the other day for example he
was 14 years old and he said you know
what i wish i could have i wish i just
had the right to be able to go ahead and
pray and to be able to read the bible in
school and he said my teachers have
actually banned me from being able to do
so you know
outside outside of the fact that they've
all read they already do for the most
part restrict bibles do you think that
in the same context the bible would be
inappropriate for young kids to read
no i don't think in the bible i mean i
mean
but i think the whole point is though
shouldn't that be up to the parents to
be able to go ahead and make these
things shouldn't shouldn't it actually
be parental rights and not actually just
the teachers unions who are saying this
is the curriculum we're going to speech
and again going back to how joe biden
calls you know everyone who's maga or
america first extremist now you've got
these actual teachers unions who are
actually saying that if you're a parent
who doesn't want certain things to be
taught to your children you're now a
domestic terrorist i mean this this is
the type of thing and you know this is
only one of many bills i mean one of the
biggest bills i want to look at right
now is the banning of you know purchased
by foreigners to you know buy up our
farmlands especially china i mean this
is something that's really important to
me because we have to understand this
economic resource warfare and the fact
that our farmlands and our actual you
know residences are being bought up by
china russia and other nations who are
trying to stop affordability and
availability of housing who are trying
to prevent the actual you know growth of
our actual domestic products when it
comes to our agricultural sector things
like this i mean there's a lot in
indiana just passed this law actually
last year where they actually ban
foreign ownership of their farmlands you
know there is so many things that we
have to write on this ship and that's
you know part of the reason why i'm
running is to try and make sure that
we're prioritizing america over
foreigners american energy over foreign
oil our borders over ukrainian borders
our veterans over illegals and our
children over teachers if you could give
a congressman something oh
well i want to wrap up that point on uh
the the explicit nature of you know
explicit depictions in the bible the
meme uh versus ezekiel 23 20 that talks
about um the size of the man that the
woman liked and the emissions of the man
and things like that and i think you
know my view on it is
parents should be absolutely especially
with with the bible like teaching their
kids about what they find to be
appropriate the issue with the schools
is they're keeping it a secret from the
parents well but sunday school taught
something totally different than what
you learned when you were so i remember
going to school for example on or going
to uh when i was younger sunday school
where
my grandparents would go into the main
hall and then we kind of went into the
children's area and we would learn
things like david and goliath or you
know you know it should be up to the
parent when their actual child are
taught these things i mean it should be
that's the whole point of the birds and
the bee stories should be taught by the
parents it should never be taught when i
when i grew up look there is no i hate
when people say there's an over
sexualization of children no no there
should be no sexualization of children
that should be left up to the parental
rights that should be left up to the
actual parents on when they feel that
their children are ready to hear certain
things this is why for example that when
i would deploy to them you know to
combat i wouldn't explain what my job is
or what i've done in war to my wife the
same way i would explain to my
six-year-old for example yeah you know
there's a time and the issue is when the
teacher does without your consent or
knowledge and keeps it a secret and says
don't tell your parents like if a
teacher went to a kid and said
you know your father is a murderer and
he goes around and he does this that or
otherwise and they don't tell your
parents i told you this is a problem the
parents have right to know so anyway i i
ask because i think you know for for
some of this material that they want to
show kids
yeah when the parents deem it
appropriate with at their discretion not
the school's doing it in secret keeping
it from the parents be it any kind of
explicit depiction see and i think that
we shouldn't even have this in the
school system because then no matter how
woke the teacher is they don't have the
materials in the schools to actually
teach for them to begin with and that's
why i looked at the publishing house
bills for the exact reason but i mean
you know
again that's that's why i asked the
question like do you think the bible
should be out of public schools i don't
actually but then the bible has
depictions and it is no understood but
it should be one of those things where i
think that the individual parents should
have a right to build again i go back to
what i was talking about with the sunday
school versus sitting in the actual main
hall you know you learn two different
things other materials that are like
work or whatever i'm not telling you
that should be taught by these teachers
but should that be available for
students if they wanted to go and you
know read the bible during their library
time or whatever the case may be why
shouldn't it be i think the bible is
also sometimes there are parts of the
bible that are age-appropriate right
there are some explicit parts of the
bible that doesn't mean you ban the book
but that doesn't mean you have to teach
it to to the five-year-olds even right
we don't you know but the five-year-olds
know that jesus carried the cross but
they don't have to watch the passion of
the christ right i mean like you you can
get the point across my point without
having to get into like well well you
know the nail actually went through like
whoa whoa
if the parents say
i would like this teacher to teach my
child about the bible which includes all
of it
in terms you know we can edit selective
parts out there's nothing wrong with
that well in the same way because the
kid's not appropriate same would be true
for inappropriate you know explorations
of you know like like i don't want to
say explicitly genderqueer because
there's questions about ideology but a
book that includes you know coming of
age sexual discussions you could argue
it should be available for the teachers
but they should avoid those topics
without unless the parents consent right
um
like they can read around it and say i'm
going to read to you about billy going
for joy right in his dad's car it was a
problem or the story of johnny who
fought his bully yeah but we're not
going to read the part where billy goes
on his first because then every kid in
the class can be like we got to get the
first date part yo oh it's all about
that first part i don't understand the
moral difference then between allowing
them to just grab the bible and and
laugh and point to the depictions of the
horse-sized male girth you know what i
mean can you show me where in the bible
that actually is ezekiel 23 20 is no but
my point is that there is no actual like
photo of of these that's why i asked you
text depictions were well i think that
definitely has to do with something when
it comes to age group obviously i mean i
don't see that many uh second graders
running to the bible uh you know
unfortunately but i mean when you talk
about when you're seven graders but but
here's why but here's my point though we
did when i was my everybody
yeah but my reason in saying that is is
that when you have something which is
like genderqueer for example which is in
cartoon fashion
right you are actually building that
with the idea of trying to
uh
encourage some of the youth to be able
to go and at least look at the photos of
these things
the image is dangerous because images
which is why i'm asking if like textual
depictions are you know comparable to
image but i i i think it's fairly
obvious images can be substantially
wrong i'm also curious as to what the
lesson is that the teacher is trying to
get across like and i feel gross i'm not
going to lie it feels like you're
committing a crime but i have seen
because i have friends who are involved
in this in this movement as well i have
seen some of these third and fourth
grade primers and
seen the imagery and read the story and
i'm like what the hell class is this
like what what's the purpose the purpose
of this story is to
teach four-year-olds it's not based on
curriculum sorry sorry we're we're back
we gotta go super chat smash the like
button subscribe to this channel which
it kindly if you haven't already and
head over to timcast.com we have a
members only segment coming up at about
11 p.m
let's uh get to the super chats
tyler turducken says tim i'm non-binary
my pronouns are ultra and
that's cute i like that that is nice
dreadnought trucking llc says you never
read my super chats oh great super chat
thank you very much
good one all right
let's see johnny uh atchison says i was
one of the 30 year old johns you
mentioned earlier today tim thanks for
the shout out
i was talking i was talking about
demographics with like the the
independent voters and how independent
voters 2-1 don't like joe biden and 18
to 34-year-olds have i think the highest
disapproval of joe biden for age group
among the different that's crazy wow and
so then i was like that's us i was like
right now you at home you're a 30 year
old guy named john or bill or something
so there you go he was john he was john
that's right that was you john atchison
i was specifically referring to you
so i saw your post on facebook i'm like
that guy i'm gonna shout him out he's
like one of the last guys named john i
thought all 30 year olds now are called
like preston and bookcase and bookcases
like example john
crime guy
yes yeah they like isn't who who named
their kid crime fighter someone did
i'm not kidding i think it might have
been july or something like that someone
someone oppressed like jennifer lawrence
no i think he might be like penn
jillette or something like that
look it up i want to find
apple was gwen stefani's kid apple yeah
diego diaz says argentina got a
government and now four out of 10 kids
can't have three meals a day i'm from
south america and here people
people are rejecting woke ideology now
that we see the misery it brings along
good
i can't find that i can't find it
argentina you can't look up crime
fighter named child crime fighter yeah
crown fighter named
named child crime fighter come on
i put crime fighter kid didn't that
didn't work you didn't type in named
child crime fighter 1900 argentina
was crushing america in gdp yeah penn
jillette penn gillette it was moxie
crime fighter is the kid moxie crime
fighter there you go all right all right
michael reilly says hey tim really
enjoyed uh your show i just started
listening a bit ago my friend suggested
it and it's pretty enlightening
uh uh
have have also said sometimes you help
with
pet surgeries
you mean like shouting out gofundme i
mean that's when people super chatted i
guess
jamie w says altoona pa here we were
hanging out there a few months ago at
the skate park just bought several acres
on the top of a mountain designing the
bardominium now the need for
homesteading and self-sufficiency has
never been greater ian love you bro love
you too she's got to get rabbit traps
you know mm-hmm rabbits free food you
just can't sustain yourself often i've
been all showing you actually protein
poisoning as a result however there is a
trick to that which is that if you
actually
put the bones over the fire and you can
actually crunch the bones there is
enough marrow to give you fat oh hell
yeah look at this
fyi secrets what's up with thermal deep
earth drilling like is that potential
energy source in the future the steam
heat produced by that yeah i mean it's
like geothermal energy on steroids again
great idea in theory
let it let it work and and let it
actually prove its concept before we
start closing does it go back to what
you said which is not government funded
but investor funded so we can actually
make sure that we have a white paper in
testing to make sure it's it's
sustainable energy cyclic ops says
cyclic ops says tim i was just listening
to you earlier earlier video and it's
true younger people like trump my bro
just turned 17 today and he has a flag
of trump with a machine gun in his room
because look
that's that's what they're trying to do
dark maga but it doesn't work because
joe biden is like
gooey and and frail joe biden's kind of
i'm sorry donald trump is kind of crazy
so donald trump as this meme riding a
tank with like machine guns or on a
velociraptor makes you laugh because
it's like look i i'll go back to my age
group you know you got donald trump who
would be like the he-man you have biden
who in his last speech looked like
skeletor you know he's like this someone
needs to make like a trump anime i've
seen like the manga where they've made
jokes about like you need like a
legitimate like donald trump anime style
like dragon ball z kind of fight like i
have the power and then he becomes
muscular i want to see someone make
donald
trump remember
on mtv they used to do like the
celebrity death match yeah
there you go the claymation stuff yes
that was awesome can melania be like the
scantily clad like like you know
clutching his leg like all those
with a sword you know she's got a sword
over her i think one big reason why
people love trump is because they see
the reaction that people have to it and
that they're getting freaked out and
then it gives them a sense of
empowerment to know that they're
contributing to someone else's emotions
you know they want to be relevant
that's kind of an unfortunate i mean the
thing that people got attracted to as
well is that president actually and this
sounds bizarre given his his success and
his his you know the fact that he has is
a billionaire
but he related to the everyday american
people and he fought for them and and
that's really what what drew people and
that's really what changed the
conservative movement from being that
wine and cheese to the beer in blue
jeans i think courage is also attractive
look at joe rogan look at this podcast
people who are courageous and say things
and they know they're going to get in
trouble and people try to cancel them
and they keep saying it that attracts
people that is true
is attractive but but it's also kind of
you know
i i feel like courage is
facing down your fear and trying to get
the job done but i feel like you know
i've been talking to a lot of people
about how scared say like celebrities
are you know they secretly support you
they don't like the woke up they won't
speak out and i'm like courage would be
them
speaking out that's clint eastwood but i
kind of feel like for me it's more
indifference
just like what are they gonna do i don't
care i don't care about that i don't i
have no fear of these woke lunatics like
talking crap about me what i mean well i
mean look at your response to getting
swatted once or twice or 17 times 10.
right that is supposed to silence you
look at the way this is like it happened
to marjory taylor green look at the way
this organization responded to it now
steve bannon and and if i mean if they
had if you had like hey we shouldn't do
this anymore guys it's dangerous
right i'm just saying like i i don't
think this podcast for me would be
courage
i'm excited i i i'm not facing down any
i don't i don't fear what they do like
i'm i'm trying to say like there are a
lot of people who are who have jobs that
are very
they require relationships there are
people who work in the music industry
there are people who work in these
industries where they will lose
everything if they speak out that's
courage when they do for us like we
exist in an ecosystem where we've never
had to worry about that so i'm not i
think the people who are actually coming
wait until the 87 000 irs agents get
fielded
[Laughter]
well but like at this point can i really
be scared of what is is projected to
come you know what i mean
like i don't know man look i i'm always
encouraged i'm always encouraged by
people who are willing to speak the
truth regardless of what's actually
going to come as a result of it and
that's that for me is still courage
because it's sometimes it's the fear of
the unknown as well a lot of people
they'll say things not knowing what
potentially could come from it
and i just like the fact that americans
as a whole we need to stop being the
silent majority we need to actually
start speaking up we need to understand
that our civic duties and our civic
rights are something that's important to
us and we need to start electing real
statesmen not just the everyday
politician and again if we want to
change the cycle
you have to do that by electing people
in office who actually speak for you
right
noah zork says texas native javelinas
travel in packs up to the high 20s
they're as smart as dogs and break open
doors and containers all the time with
teamwork
that's awesome that's so cool
are they are they
poor sign they're they're pig people
they're in the pig family are they
little pigs are they like little or they
like rats so they roasted not see that
photo that is clearly a pig
yeah javelinas so they're pigs what a
wacky little animal you have in texas
texas says that's weird i think they're
in arizona too and arizona peccaries
speak easyofficial says if the
apocalypse is coming you'll need a band
to put in some work for you at tim cast
records we are speakeasy we'd love to
work with a cool record label that is
doing something new that's awesome well
we'll figure it out we've been having uh
so the best news is um
there's good news and bad news i don't
know exactly what's going on the the
billboard charts usually come out
tuesday but there's a monday holiday and
it's sounding like they aren't going to
count our youtube traffic which means we
basically just get bumped which is
insane because that look we have a
youtube audience so obviously youtube is
where we got uh you know massive play
we sold 12
520-something singles which is like
really great for an initial release we
are on a bunch of charts i don't know to
what degree but the strange thing is
also will of the people
actually charted as well which is like a
two year old song because people were
buying that i don't know where it will
be but without the youtube views being
properly listed and we'll see i think i
think they're they're telling us they're
not going to do it which is insane
because we we we even we contacted
nielsen well in advance and asked them
and they're like you're good we got you
know we we understand we talk to other
people in the industry and now they're
like well you know the thing is it's
like oh i'll be honest with you i i just
heard a couple of your songs tonight
right before the actual uh segment that
we ran and and i gotta say it was it was
really impressive like it's really great
music and i think that
this is something that a lot of the
people needs to go on wide stream i mean
this should be outside of youtube
outside of everything this is mainstream
music i mean the quality of it i mean
look you got really great vocals on this
and i i i loved it and even the one that
ian was actually kind of a backup
beyonce singer on it was really great
right
mcdonald's got a song coming out i don't
know if he announced that already didn't
he
pretty sure he did he's got a song
coming out so really excited for that
and uh i just you know i saw his story
he uh was trying to get on you know he
this he's huge tommy you've probably
heard his music and they wouldn't track
his stuff properly they were denying it
rejecting it and
surprise surprise but the the good news
is
the release was such a success
and i want to give a special thanks to
people like hassan [ __ ] and ethan klein
whose reviews really helped us
it really did because that's the kind of
press from these these leftist podcasts
were crap talking but like crap talk is
expensive when you're launching a
product and you can get major podcasts
to talk about it you normally gotta pay
tens of thousands they did it for free
because they hate me
it worked out really well what what did
president trump say
good good or bad coverage is still good
coverage that's right so anyway in
reference to speakeasy one of the things
we're talking about doing is since the
success of the song we've actually
gotten uh connected and have some deals
with industry professionals
uh
i think these people on the left need to
realize like the industry doesn't care
why you're talking about it or why
you're watching it or why you're
listening to it that kind of attention
was good so we got some deals and now
we're looking at expanding the label so
it looks like a big success and we're
going to be signing some bands and then
recording some music obviously we're
going to be starting with the music we
have in-house and then we're going to be
looking to you know maybe people like
bands like speakeasy or whatever so
appreciate all the support guys we'll
see if they actually decide to count the
youtube views which is substantial 1.7
million
we'll see
we'll see
beside thought says back in 2012 i chose
to live in the wilderness and walk from
california to florida did it uh did it
did it to make sure i could survive in
the worst case scenario 13 months best
time of my life that sounds awesome wow
it's like a good time that should have
been documented that's that's a that's a
hell of a
you know tim casta
documentary or something yeah maybe 18
months across the country 13 months
walking from california to florida
that's awesome man good that's how long
it took what shoes did you have on you
know what that's dozens of shoes
that's the desperation of people wanting
to escape california to come to the free
state of florida yeah they'll even walk
it they'll walk
the u-hauls have run out now they're
actually going to the actual nike tread
runners so we uh i was reading about
like john brown and stuff because we we
we work very close to the john brown
right headquarters
and uh
reading about
like how they would have how long it
would take to travel from say harper's
ferry to like uh frederick maryland it's
like a 15 minute drive but back then it
was like a half day or a day trip
it's like well we're here in the big
city and we're gonna we gotta go to
harpers ferry it's like get the horse
and horses got to stop and drink they
can only do so well that was the whole
point of the 20th amendment as well you
know they gave three months in between
elections and the actual times you
started because they were worried about
the time of travel now for me that's
very dangerous because now you look at
what's going on today and what you can
do and how much damage you can do in
twenty and three months
and you know this is something that
concerns me you know when when the
democrats end up losing the house and
the senate
you know how many executive orders are
going to come about as a result of that
because of the time of travel yeah
all right cigars and sig arms says if
you want an idea of what the collapse of
society will be like read the one second
after trilogy by william
fortion
well all right
we'll take a look
josh says amazon removed all their solar
stuff because it caught fire
really the other thing is i watched a
video about hail storms
yeah one hailstorm and your entire solar
output is gone again and that's that's
not good or bad that's just reality
right it's that it's that thomas soul
quote there there are no solutions there
are only trade-offs and if the american
people knew the trade-offs of going
green they would not choose it that is a
real thing solar
hail storms dust i have solar panels i
have a lot of solar gates on my farm
i've said this before on the show and
when we have two weeks of solid snow if
i don't brush my solar panels off the
gates the next time i try to move my
cattle through the gate is dead and a
dead gate is very hard to to retract
manually that's the reality of solar
that's not good or bad it's just reality
it's not real we have reliable energy
sources here in america and that's the
issue with these
unreliable energy sources as texas found
out through their own you know demise
all right robert pavezza says make a
culture get ben shapiro to cover the
devil went down to georgia you could
even parried it the liberal went down to
florida that'd be great that'd be good
um i i need to uh we need to get i like
that one we need to do we need to do a
collab on a song with ben shapiro i'm
still waiting for you to to redo chicken
city doesn't he yeah
violin or something doesn't he yeah yeah
yeah
he probably plays classical violin i
don't know why he's struggling
he's he's good enough to rock violins
probably super like you know pop or rock
or whatever oh dude if we could get ben
dancing man even just a few shots of him
making some sweet moves
so we got to get um we got to get james
o'keefe he he sings he also dances we
got to get tom mcdonald we'll work on it
then we've got ben shapiro michael
knowles jeremy bourne they'll play music
plays bass
on bass just do this this we'll call it
the grifters we'll get everybody and
come and put a song together i love it
all right let's grab some more
lost cause says daniel has tesla fix the
batteries where they do not work well in
the cold i have seen more here in north
dakota where we get weeks of minus 20
and lower in winter no they haven't and
that's again one of the trade-offs and
if you don't believe me have some fun
tonight charge your iphone 100
and put it in the freezer and wake up
tomorrow morning and see if your iphone
is still charged and the answer is your
iphone will be dead because it cannot
hold a charge below freezing it's not
good or bad it's just real so but how
does that so tesla's you can charge your
tesla all night long
but when you put your phone in the
freezer it discharges yes you your your
battery drains down to nothing but you
have to leave your leave your phone on
and just put it in the put in the
freezer that's lithium ion batteries yes
that is just the reality of them and
again your freezer if it's 31 degrees it
may not work but when you get down to 15
degrees
it doesn't lose it i know that they
probably
sucks it out like that
and sometimes it doesn't even hold the
charge wow so imagine that imagine that
was a big problem in the polar vortex in
chicago last two summers do you remember
the polar vortex two winters uh when i
worked at the at o'hare we had electric
tugs and in the winter it was like
and if you have a heated garage or even
an enclosed garage great but if you just
park your car on the driveway like i did
growing up in new york city and you
bring out the thing and you plug it in
it's not going to hold a charge but what
happens if you take your tesla out in
the middle of winter you're driving it
will the battery just be melt like your
battery will definitely not last as long
it probably won't die but i don't know
the actual percentages of how much it's
reduced by that's just the reality but
how many people in america are you
actually describing when you talk about
this heated you know garage with its own
individual charger and it's 70 000
you know with 40-year high inflation the
fact that we can't even get our supply
chain to be you know continuous i mean
how many people in california this is
the jennifer lawrence's of the world how
many people in california where they're
going to mandate electric vehicles live
in a high rise and they park on the
street
all right spoch says while listening to
you guys talk about energy california
literally sent out an alert to phones
about conserving electricity until 9 00
pm
there you go damn
brave new world
i keep thinking about lightning and
ocean water they're like where are we
going to get all our water from where's
our electricity and they'll look back on
humans what infants we were at this
stage of humanity it is important are
you franklin in this right now i think
so it is inconceivable gavin newsom
could win re-election with the state of
his state in terms of just crime
homelessness poverty drug use i still
think larry elder should have actually
beat him out and and the electricity
that is your and again maybe you should
you should be able to have a nuclear
reactor in your backyard i agree with
that that was the best part of of of
back to the future when he's got mr
fission right you should be able to have
your own but that is gavin newsom's job
and he can provide it for his
constituents he's unqualified sorry all
right peter gohak says can you guys give
my wife kim a shout out been trying to
get her to watch you she finally did a
few days ago and today she said when is
tim cast on get off your phone and turn
it on lol thanks tim shout out kim yeah
nice job thanks for watching it's great
it's good news huh that is pretty cool
brendan mcgrath music says biden clearly
called out maga civilians in his 9 1
speech now his twitter and walk backs
with the media he says congressional
maga republicans the gaslighting begins
that he always meant congress yeah
because the polling is really bad
we all knew it
oh that's good so he's only referring to
america's first conservatives yeah
running for office great yeah not the
people who voted it in and who want it
just the representatives
i think that's what they call
gaslighting when they say something but
then say they didn't say it is that
gasoline
nathan l says check out the fund for
officer matt tidman thanks to the
progressive prison reform in m.a
department of corrections a murderer had
access to free weights and bash tidman
over the head he's in a medical coma
with brain bleeds fighting for his life
man sorry to hear that's crazy
let's see we just had one where to go
julian vega says abortion issue is
taking a lot of women to the democrats
almost like the abortion issue was
brought up before the midterms on
purpose
maybe i don't think the supreme court
planned it i think they got it when they
got it and they
went with it as well well i think that
justice alito was right in saying that
this was not a constitutional issue that
should have been heard by scottish to
begin with and it should fall back into
the individual state rights i think ruth
bader ginsburg said something similar
right
that she didn't she didn't think that
this was the right way to legislate it
should have been she agreed with the
outcome but she said the lord and she
said the law is not gonna stand she knew
it wasn't gonna stand and little did she
know that her intransigence that
resigning because she wanted hillary to
nominate her replacement would lead to
it's not standing but that's just what
we call irony
josh bushnell says this is why jesus
said truly i tell you it is hard harder
for someone who is rich to enter the
kingdom of heaven and he said it is
what was it it's easier to fit a camel
through than i have an eagle than for a
rich man and to the kingdom of heaven
yep except the eye of a needle is a door
in jerusalem it's not actually the
needle of a knee he says jennifer
lawrence is in danger she probably does
not understand
all right all right poor jennifer
lawrence wicked says you are looking so
slim daniel what's your strategy oh my
god i love this person
uh not eating farming
farm you know what summertime on a farm
is
sweating non-stop i shower at this point
three times a day you just walk
miles and miles and yes i have lost a
decent amount of weight and it is
literally just from sweating because
farming is exhausting are you fasting
i just sometimes you don't have time to
eat you know or sometimes you're just so
hot and sweaty you're not hungry yeah
and there are days especially when it's
in the 90s that it's just you're just
sweaty and gross and you don't want to
eat just want to drink so yeah so thank
you oh my gosh i appreciate that you
made my day i also uh i got to tell you
i mean not to sound like a kiss-ass but
you you inspired me as well every time i
was on the show you got skinnier and
skinny and skinnier but i know you do
some weird stuff like where you don't
eat or you only eat like rice don't eat
sugar i don't eat rice water it's the
opposite or whatever you do i know you
have some weird things so yeah i had a
uh you know i mostly just cut sugar out
so it's like if i'm gonna eat i'll go
for the you know the no bread we went to
a lot of alcohol erythritol as an
alcohol sugar no i hate that stuff yeah
i don't like it that much but it's not
cane sugar and what's the other one i
just don't do sugar i just
i like
i put heavy cream in my coffee it tastes
amazing nitro cold brew with heavy
creams like drinking a chocolate
milkshake it's it's nuts you ever have
that it's so good yeah i drink my my
coffee black
i love the heavy cream i put coconut
water in mine which has a little bit of
sugar
gotta say i've never heard of that it's
freaking fantastic for dinner a little
peanut butter powder as well for dinner
i had uh uh slow cooked chicken with uh
peppers
and coffee daniel's loving it oh peanut
butter no peanut butter and powder
coffee because it's too acidic oh ask
jack yeah it kind of cuts the actually i
heard it from jack jack's the one that
introduced me to peanut butter powder
right yeah a scoop of peanut butter
powder no you gotta try come on are you
serious you've never you've never had
like my gut reaction was was you want to
try it now it is gross it's creamy my
gut reaction was to heave coffee peanut
butter milkshake no i i i just prefer my
coffee with coffee
coffee coffee yeah i like pouring cow
fat right up in it
all right we just had a good one there
we go matthew lincoln says he's a
current member of the military nothing
makes me wants to serve nothing makes me
want to serve my country more than my
president calling me a threat to the
country
and let me let me tell you this this is
a real issue you know a lot of our
recruitment issue isn't just because of
the unconstitutional forced vaccinations
which is an intentional purge but the
idea that he literally is kind of
purging out the military because of the
lack of morale and and and that's really
an issue for us i mean look at the end
of the day i think that every single
member who has been purged out of the
military as a result of them refusing
the unconstitutional vaccine mandate
should be entitled to 100 of their
benefits and for those who have served
15 to 16 or even more years they should
be allowed back in the military to
continue their service and go into their
retirement i don't think that an
unconstitutional vaccine
should be the reasoning for you being
discharged out of the military do you
remember that russian military
recruitment video
yeah that was just like super
alpha
same as the chinese same
watch that video like i wanted to join
the russian military they watch they
they switch to the american one where
they're talking about pronouns well the
american one was like a cartoon and she
was she was like the life of jill and my
two moms taught me how to
protest and then i became again this
goes back to so my gosh i want to join
the russians when i was in the military
i was in the military during the bl you
can b days and i can well as far as the
army and so i can tell you right now you
know the ideas of not being not being
about you know pronouns or crt or
inclusiveness or diversity or things
like that this is what i would tell
every single politician who thinks that
that's important as opposed to increased
lethality things like that
go walk through
arlington yeah go tell me how those
alabaster colored you know headstones
are laid out are they laid out by gender
are they laid out by religion are they
laid out by your diversity no
they're not
at the end of the day we all bleed green
and that's something that we understood
in the military so the idea of dividing
our military weakening our military and
constitutionally purging our military
is un-american
right on man i'm so in line with that i
would love to let these people back in
receive a hero's welcome back especially
with knowing now what we know about
covid like come on
amen brother
ladies and gentlemen if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends head over to
timcast.com become a member because
we're gonna have an uncensored not so
family-friendly members only show at 11
pm it's gonna be a lot of fun we usually
have a lot of fun things get spicy
sometimes you can follow the show at tim
cast irl you can follow me at tim cast
cor do you want to shout anything out uh
do you want to tell everybody that you
know look at the end of the day if you
don't like what's going on in america
you need to get out and vote you need to
understand that your civic duty is out
there you need to understand that if you
like the increased gas prices the lack
of supply chain the open borders the
soft on crime policies the increased
criminality things like this get out and
do something i'm not telling you to vote
left or right all the republicans are
the right way but what i'm telling you
is is that at the end of the day
you have a voice and no one should be
able to silence that so get out make
sure you vote on november 8th
always great to be here daniel turner
daniel turner ptf on all platforms
powerofthefuture.com uh if you care
about energy issues and if you care
about virginia sheep farms the
preeminent virginia sheep farm is
bristol farm virginia i know lydia
follows us and you like us all the time
which makes me happy and we just got a
whole bunch of new girls and you can go
check them out they're very very sweet
scotties so i've been following you guys
on instagram thank you finding some
amazing amazing video
i see you don't follow me on
anything
hey you got a hat behind you is that
merch it is merch
you know what i will be happy to go
ahead and provide that to you right now
tell me more
oh wait tell tell the world on the you
know what i don't sell merch i don't
drift off people i actually give it so
if you're actually wanting to go ahead
and represent some mills attire then by
all means go ahead and reach out to me
thank you corey cool bye everyone
and i'm also here thank you guys all for
tuning in this evening this fun tuesday
night thank you corey and thank you
daniel for coming and that sheep farm is
just to die for i have to say check it
out for sure on instagram you guys can
follow me on twittermines.com at sour
patch lids as well as sour patch let's
stop me we will see you all over at
timcast.com just about an hour or so
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you